Have you been here since he had a kid?
Yeah,
I was here last,
right about four months after I didn't
sleep at all.
It's amazing.
I was able to talk for and now your kid
is how old?
Thirteen months.
Wait till they start talking.
He.
Oh,
he says,
I mean he's,
he's now his new thing is he says all
done,
all done.
So he'll say it like he'll say it before
I change his diaper because he doesn't
want me to go through that.
You know what I'm saying?
Hold on,
hold on.
Don't say it like a lane his crib and
say it like when he's ready to get out
of bed early in the morning.
And I'm like waiting.
And I'm like maybe looking back to sleep
now being a scientist and having a
child.
Are you,
are you like cognizant of like every
single factor that's taking place like
nutrition,
all the input,
emotional input environment must be kind
of mind blowing
and mind exhausting too.
Yes it is.
I'll give you an example right now
because we're traveling,
right?
And um,
you know,
I,
I'm,
I'm pretty this the BPA plastic bottles,
you know,
I'm having to give him water and he's
like obsessed for whatever reason.
He's obsessed with drinking.
I brought his like,
you know,
nice cop,
but he doesn't wanna drink it out of his
cup,
he wants to drink it,
all these plastic bottles.
It's novel and crinkly sound and
anyways,
you know,
so I'm like all I can think about is the
VPA and you know,
am I,
am I exposing them to too much and
what's it doing?
And is that BPA,
is it leach only when it gets hot,
is that how it works?
So.
And that's another thing I was thinking
about in my hotel today,
making a coffee with one of those,
I'm one of those paper cups.
It has the plastic lining and like I
don't know what's in the plastic lining,
bpa or some of the BPA alternatives,
which have also been shown to how does
bpa stands for Bisphenol a.
So to answer your question,
there's been experiments done that have
shown here.
So boiling,
boiling water and putting it in plastic
increases the BPA that leeches into the
solution into the water by like 55 fold.
So yes,
definitely heating up it was like way
worse.
And so one of the things I'm always now
thinking about is,
you know,
going to starbucks,
whatever the plastic lining they're
putting in those cups when you get your
hot tea or your coffee.
I don't know if there's BPA,
but there's now studies that have come
out in these studies have been done in
animals that show like bps and some of
the other bp of replacements also have
negative consequences on the endocrine
system,
on reproduction and some,
in some cases they're passed onto
multiple generations now.
How much of that is actually translates
to humans?
It's unknown,
but there have been studies,
at least with Bpa that have shown that,
you know,
you give a person a single dose of BPA
and it disrupts their insulin
sensitivity.
It also plays a role in like I'm causing
problems with in vitro fertilization,
so disrupting hormones and things like
that.
So I was really cognizant about it
during pregnancy because,
you know,
typically we do detoxify,
detoxify it quite well.
The half life is like less than five
hours and we excrete it through urine.
It also comes out through sweat by the
way,
which is really good.
Um,
but pregnant,
but you know,
when you're pregnant for whatever
reason,
the placenta,
it,
you know,
you,
you're basically take the BPA your body,
it's in your body and your,
your liver will inactivate it to this,
like more benign compound.
But when it crosses over the placenta,
it gets in,
it gets activated again.
And so it's like,
that's why they effects are much more
robust always on like the developing
fetus.
And so I was really made sure I was like
not drinking anything out of a plastic
bottle or anything like that,
don't when I,
while I was pregnant,
just because,
I mean,
I don't know.
Right.
At the end of the day there's,
there's a lot of studies that have been
done in animals and just how much of
that,
you know,
translate how significant is.
It's really hard to say.
Um,
but it certainly concerned
it was probably a compounding effect,
right,
with all the other environmental
factors,
pollution,
particulates in the air,
chemicals,
all the other jazz that we take into our
body all the time.
Right?
Yeah.
And then the fact that actually aging
bottles,
like as you,
for whatever reason,
as a bottle sits,
like if you keep using,
for example,
the study was done with baby bottles,
if you keep using a baby bottle and
putting liquid in as the bottle aged
more BPA was leeched out into the
liquid.
So for whatever,
I know it's just.
So it's another thing I'm thinking about
with all my son's stuff.
It's like everything's plastic and he's
chewing on.
It's like,
you know,
at some point you just can't,
like there's,
you can't control everything.
Right.
How many kids do you think you're going
to have right now?
Um,
one is,
it's,
I am so satisfied and full of so much
joy and it's a lot of work.
Um,
and I,
you know,
he's 13 months,
so I've,
I've only had them a little bit over a
year.
So right now I'm,
I'm really happy with him being special.
I don't know,
I think it's likely that maybe one,
but I'm not gonna like,
you know,
say for sure it's,
it's a lot of work.
It's a lot of work.
Yeah.
And you know,
it just adding another,
it's like,
well,
you know,
I've put a lot of energy and time,
spent a lot of time with him doing lots
of things and of course all the
nutrition and all that.
But um,
it's.
How do you do that with too.
It's,
it's very satisfying though.
Watching them play with their siblings.
It's really interesting.
Like my two youngest,
my eight and my 10,
like watching them play together,
it's,
it's adorable watching them hold hands
and do stuff together.
That's really fun.
Again,
they developed a very unique bond.
They fight all the time over nothing
like Gimme that it's mine.
It's my like in all of a sudden like,
whoa,
Whoa,
whoa.
What happened?
You know,
like there's always like some blow up
because they have zero control of their
emotions.
Anything that goes on,
it's just a flood gate is either on
or it's off and but they're really good
at apologizing too,
which is really interesting.
We've taught them how to do that.
How to just say,
look,
everybody gets emotional.
It's okay,
apologize and hug it out and
yeah,
I think it's also another thing that is
really important in the teaching or your
children how to be happy.
Like you know,
cause that's important.
They see that though they'll see that
new,
you know,
the imitate their environment.
If they see,
you know,
that you know how to be happy and that
you can turn things around and you not
to make light of situations and they'll,
they'll,
they take on these behavior patterns.
Really,
that's one of the more fascinating
things is watching kids go,
wow,
what are you going to do?
You know,
like when you do,
what are you going to do?
And then you see them go on,
Huh,
what are you going to do?
And you're like,
wow.
Watching an eight year old figured that
out was kind of cool.
Yeah,
that's nice.
That's nice to know.
Like right now,
my son,
he's almost always just happy,
you know,
and I'm thinking about like future he's
going to girl problems and girl breaks,
just anything,
you know,
where it's the thought,
well if he's gay.
Yeah.
And that's where I'm like,
you know,
all the endocrine disruptors.
Oh my God,
I'm gay.
Yeah.
Who knows,
who knows what's happening.
Yeah,
I mean,
and what's,
what's of major concern to me is living
in a major metropolitan areas with the
constant pollution.
And I was reading a study that was
talking about living in any major
metropolitan area like New York City can
take many years off of your life just
from living there.
It will shorten your life.
Yeah.
I've been reading multiple studies over
the years about air pollution and you
know,
there's,
there's compounds in air pollution that
are carcinogens like benzine and there's
also the particulate matter and how
these,
you know,
how air pollution is,
um,
increasing the risk for stroke,
heart attack,
Alzheimer's disease.
Um,
and this is like in dose dependent
manners and of course has all sorts of
confounding factors and you can never
really show causality,
although some animal studies have been
showing causality.
Um,
it's,
and,
and some of these things are really bad
in developing nations that don't have a
lot of regulatory regulations on,
um,
for example,
like automobile exhaust and so some,
some developing countries have like
children coming down with strokes and
stuff like early,
like young teenage.
So,
um,
and it's been,
this has of course been linked to air
pollution.
Uh,
so it's,
it's definitely a concern and then
there's all sorts of studies talking
about,
um,
you know,
of course asthma,
but you know,
happiness and,
and,
and bring function and all that,
you know,
so,
and it's something like I live off of a
busy road and then there's noise
pollution,
which is another.
I mean,
so it's like something that I've been
like really,
really aware of and trying to like move
out away from a busy traffic areas,
particularly for my son,
you know,
because I'm just very concerned about
the health risks.
Yeah.
I wonder also the in the impact of just
being in an urban environment and the
fact that it's not really natural and
that may be a person who's an adult
could enjoy living in Manhattan and
decide that they get a thrill out of
living in the city,
but for a baby to grow up around all
that concrete and glass and all these
sharp hard edges and right angles that
it's maybe not conducive to healthy
brain development or that's not like
what your,
what your body or your brain is
naturally craving and there's been
studies looking at,
for example,
like people that exercise and I
metropolitan area versus like out in
like a park nature and that,
you know,
all sorts of measurements of depressive
symptoms that are measured after and the
ones that measured or that nature or
run.
We're far better at,
you know,
basically feeling,
feeling happier after after their run.
Then the people that didn't,
metropolitan city.
Does that make sense?
No,
I mean I think that's why people like
central park in New York City was just
say in a way asis.
Yeah.
You get something.
I mean,
it's really a great place.
It's really quite big.
One of the things about central park
when you're in it,
you're like,
wow,
this is weird that this is in the middle
of the city,
but it's a brilliant move to have this
one area.
I mean,
you think about how much that real
estate would be worth.
It just said just to shove buildings in
there.
I mean Manhattan is one of the most
pricey real estate places on the planet
earth and yet in the middle of it they
have this big open public park area that
anyone could just wander around,
sit by a tree.
It's really a very,
very smart move.
It is,
it is.
Nice.
La should have something like that.
Is the air pollution.
Do you know if the air pollution with
like in Manhattan?
It's terrible,
terrible in Manhattan to La.
I think they're probably equally sucky,
but the thing that is bothering me,
um,
is not just the air pollution in terms
of like the exhaust fumes and exhaust
the smells,
but also the brake dust.
You know,
when I first started paying attention to
brake dust and I would always clean it
off my wheels,
but I would never think about it like,
oh,
there's dust that's on my wheels.
I would say,
oh,
it's just dust.
And he was then someone was explaining
to me to know that's an environmental
hazard that you're breathing in.
If you live in that environment,
when you're around,
know if you're on Broadway and cars are
constantly hitting their breaks around
you.
There's a puff of that brake dust has
getting in the air with every pump,
the brakes,
and you're just taking that disgusting
stuff into your lungs.
Yeah.
That particulate matter,
that's really tiny and stuff because
that's like Mesothelioma,
right?
You're taking in the particulate matter
from his bestest.
So in the same you'd think there'd be
similar mechanisms may not going to lead
to immediate family,
Oma,
but that there would be similar
mechanisms at play that are like,
you know,
damaging organs.
Good to visit.
Not good to stay.
That's what I think.
I mean,
my.
I have no desire.
I don't even like living here.
I think there's too many people.
Yeah,
it's,
I definitely don't like driving here,
like it's like it's,
it's really bad how much is the
difference between here and we're in San
Diego.
San Diego is definitely bad during um,
you know,
the typical times people are either
going to work or coming,
coming home from work.
Uh,
but it's,
it's,
it's nothing like La.
I mean la is orders of magnitude worse
for sure.
If you're not doing clinical research,
you could do a lot of your stuff
somewhere else.
Have you thought about being somewhere
else?
Um,
so my family's in San Diego and uh,
it's really nice having my mom in
particular because she helps out a lot
with my son so that I can,
uh,
get some work done too,
which is important and I really,
we could live,
you know,
a little bit further out.
I mean there's,
there are places like that are still
within like 40 minute drive to like,
you know,
downtown San Diego beaches and stuff
that are,
that are nice.
And um,
so that is something that we are
considering buying.
We're just a little quieter,
definitely quieter no matter what it's
going to be.
You know,
because we live,
there's just,
it's a busy road and there's fire sirens
and you know,
my son likes the fire sirens,
but there are,
there have been times when there have
been loud motorcycles and he is like,
concerned,
like you can see a look on it,
like it's,
you know,
so,
so it kind of worries me as well.
Um,
but definitely it's,
it's,
uh,
it's important to get away from that.
It's a goal for sure.
Now,
before the podcast started,
you were telling me that you wrote a 30
page paper on the Carnivore Diet.
It's not a paper.
Well,
it's,
I definitely spent a lot of time pages.
I thought about it for a long time and
yes,
there's 30 pages of thoughts and
references.
Were you stunned that this became,
I mean,
this is a very recent thing.
Yeah.
People were just eating meat.
Well,
at first,
um,
when I was,
when I think Dan told me about it like a
couple of years ago even,
like,
and I thought there's no way.
I was like,
I just ignored it.
I don't have time for that.
So yeah,
I definitely,
um,
dismissed it when I,
when I first heard about it,
but it's definitely been something that
has gained a lot of traction,
you know,
send it disturb you that it's getting
traction.
Well,
I definitely have concerns.
Um,
I think that the,
the most important question really is
what is attracting someone to try such a
very restrictive diet,
you know,
that potentially could be dangerous
without published evidence or any sort
of longterm studies and things like
that.
So I think that the first question
really is,
well,
why are people doing this?
And so looking on the Internet and try
to like read about people's anecdotes.
Um,
it seems as though a lot of people are
drawn to it because they have some sort
of autoimmune problem and so they try
this diet and it improves their
autoimmune symptoms and I see that seems
to be a real common theme in at least if
you,
if you look in the blogosphere ears and
stuff like that.
Um,
so that's,
I think kind of a good place to start
where it's like,
well,
you know,
what are people doing this for?
And then,
uh,
so that's,
that's kind of an important question and
I'm so,
so further reading about this diet is
sort of sort of think about,
well,
okay,
well what's going on?
It's really important when you have like
something that leads to an effect to
understand the mechanism because the
mechanism is what's leading to this
effect.
And so if you can do something that's
potentially not so dangerous or risky,
then understanding the mechanism will
help you because then you can find other
ways to do it.
Right?
And so,
um,
if you look at,
at a published studies on people that
eat low carb,
high protein diets,
which is pretty common,
is that they're,
there's changes that happen in a variety
of different endocrine factors.
I'm like,
you know,
you're less insulin that's changing your
satiety and hunger hormones,
Leptin and Ghrelin and people become
more satiated and they actually eat
less.
And this has been shown in multiple
studies so people actually eat less when
they're having a higher protein diet,
which makes sense to because protein is
more satiating,
uh,
as well.
Um,
and also there's also been studies on
what's called food habituation a,
we're basically,
so habituation is when you're constantly
exposed to the same stimulus,
you sort of have a decreased response to
that stimulus where there's been
intervention trials where people are
given the same food every single day,
both non obese and obese people versus
people that are given the same food once
a week.
And the people that are given the same
food every single day that they start to
eat less calories so they start to eat
less.
I'm naturally started to calorie
restrict themselves.
Um,
so I mean,
and that's,
it's Kinda like a dietary monotony sort
of thing.
So I think there are any,
if you read and the people out there on
the blogs talking about this diet,
they say I like I'm eating less,
I only eat twice a day.
I'm fasting.
So that's,
people are talking about that as well.
So I think there's published evidence to
kind of explain that.
And also there's,
you know,
people saying,
yeah,
I eat less.
So that's an important point because one
thing that's really known to affect
autoimmunity is caloric restriction.
And fasting,
like it's probably one of the most well
known,
um,
technologies that you can intervene and
have improvements in autoimmune disease.
So,
um,
some of that has to do with the fact
that you can sort of reset your immune
system.
There have been animal studies and human
studies,
a lot of this done by Dr Valter Longo at
USC.
Uh,
he's done some prolonged fasting.
I'm in animals.
And also there's been sort of like a
fasting mimicking diet done in humans,
which kind of a very low calorie diet.
This is meant to mimic fast.
Um,
and those have shown that,
um,
you basically kind of crossover because
fasting is a type of stress you
crossover into this like stronger stress
response where you're not only like
cleaning away all the gunk in the size
of the cells.
People talk about a topic,
you lot when they're talking about
fasting,
you clean away things like damaged piece
of DNA,
protein aggregates,
things like that.
Mitochondria that are damaged get
cleared out.
But you also sort of start to clear away
entire cells through a process called
apoptosis.
And in animal studies,
what's been shown is that if you do,
for example,
a 72 hour fast,
you can clear away about 30 percent of
the immune system and that and,
and,
and we replenish it with like brand new
healthy immune cells and literally like
Oregon's shrink once during the fasting
and then they have like re-expand
because you're activating the stem cells
and you're,
you're,
you know,
basically replenishing all your damaged
old cells with new ones.
Um,
will voltaren as shown in animal
studies.
Also,
auto immune cells tend to be selectively
killed off and replaced with non on
immune cells.
So he's also done a clinical study,
a pilot clinical study with people with
multiple sclerosis during this fast
mimicking diet for one month,
sorry for one week.
And I'm there in their symptoms
improved.
Also,
a ketogenic diet was done side by side.
And ketogenic Diet also improve symptoms
of autoimmunity.
So those both were done in humans.
So I think that,
um,
you know,
understanding that some of these
mechanisms that are at play and that
fasting itself and caloric restriction
both have been shown to improve
autoimmunity.
You may be tapping into something there
by eating less.
That's one possibility.
Um,
in addition,
there's been studies,
clinical studies in humans were that
were done.
They were basically fasted for 24 hours
every other day for 15 days,
so they had like a total of seven days
of fasting and these were also people
with multiple sclerosis.
And there's profound changes in the
microbiome that started happening.
And this was an in line with basically
I'm having,
you know,
a lot of anti inflammatory cytokines
basically producing immune cells that
are really important for preventing
autoimmunity called t regulatory cells.
So things like that.
So that's another really important thing
to consider is,
you know,
the microbiome because the microbiome
has been linked to autoimmunity and
multiple,
multiple studies.
I mean,
it's been linked to arthritis.
It's been linked to multiple sclerosis.
It's been linked to other diseases like
Parkinson's,
which is not really autoimmune.
But,
um,
and the point of this is that,
you know,
again,
understanding mechanism and realizing,
you know,
there's other potential factors that
could be leading to an effect,
right?
It's,
it's actually,
um,
the,
the changes in the microbiome are really
important because there's actually been
a few animal studies which have led to
phase one,
phase two and phase three clinical
trials that have been done in humans.
So I'm cumins with multiple sclerosis.
We're treated with minocycline an
antibiotic,
and they've been basically the
antibiotic was shown to improve symptoms
of multiple sclerosis and because there
there's good bacteria and bad bacteria
that had been linked to autoimmunity and
getting rid of getting rid of bacteria,
you know,
the bad bacteria is going to probably
lead to improvements and that's what was
shown in animal studies.
And then in human trials.
So humans I'm taking with multiple
sclerosis,
taking motorcycling for two years.
So basically they had improvements that
delay the onset or progression of the
disease.
But then after two years those
improvements went away probably because
you're wiping out the microbiome and
eventually you're also getting rid of
the bad,
the good bacteria and so that things are
going to catch up.
Right?
So you're not just,
you may be getting rid of some of the
pathogenic bad bacteria with
antibiotics,
but eventually like you're also getting
rid of good stuff.
So long term,
you know,
you may not have those same improvements
and that.
And that's very interesting.
I think it's really important point to
understand,
um,
with,
with something like changes,
very profound changes in the microbiome
when it comes to someone just eating
meat.
So one thing to keep in mind with,
with the microbiome is that basically
the bacteria really are good at adapting
to their environment.
That's why the antibiotic resistance is
such a big deal.
And when you,
there's been human intervention studies,
when you take a human that goes from a
high fiber diet to a low fiber,
high protein or vice versa,
you get changes in their gut microbiome
that happened within 24 hours.
So within an hour you actually start to
have doubling of populations of bacteria
and within 24 to 48 hours do you
actually start to lose other.
So basically other bacteria start to die
off.
And this is at the species level,
it's really hard to change the Fila.
The Fila is more linked to longterm
dietary patterns.
Eventually you can change as well.
But,
um,
it's been shown that people that go from
a,
um,
a more high fiber to a high protein
diet,
they have changed their microbiome and
these changes are a lot of the
microbiome bacteria that are fermenting
a variety of fermentable fibers start to
leave and you actually start to get
bacteria cropping up that ferment amino
acids.
So the amino acids,
amino acids,
simple sugars,
fats,
those are mostly absorbed in the small
intestine,
but some of them make their way into the
large intestine.
And there's a whole,
you know,
group of bacteria called the
putrifactive bacteria.
And they ferment amino acids.
And some of these species of
putrifactive bacteria has been linked to
colon cancer.
There are much higher in colon cancer
patients.
Animal studies have shown,
you know,
causal links where they can basically
regressively cause a polyp to form a
tumor.
And that's because these bacteria are
making things called racine and
cadaveric,
which are damaging their genotoxic
agents that damaged the DNA inside your
colon cells.
And so,
um,
people that are typically eating like an
omnivore type of vibe where they're
eating protein and they're also eating
fermentable fiber if they're eating the
fermentable fiber that's facilitating
the growth of lactic acid producing
bacteria,
it,
that limits the growth of putrifactive
be so if you're,
if your bifidobacteria,
lactobacillus,
s mutans as Thermophilus,
those strains of bacteria are elected
acid producing bacteria,
which you'd be getting if you're,
I mean,
you,
you'd be facilitating the growth of if
you're eating plants,
mental fermentable fiber,
you're going to limit the growth of
putrifactive because they can't grow
with lactic acid.
So it's not like,
it's not a huge,
huge concern.
But the question is what happens when
you're only eating when you're only
getting immuno acids,
you know,
so is there a longterm?
So if you're,
if you're,
if you're killing off potentially some
of this pathogenic bacteria and you're
having this effect,
a positive effect,
what's going to happen long term?
It's not known.
I mean,
this data,
it hasn't really been studied at that
level,
been a few people that have,
have anecdotal stories about doing it
for 10,
20 years that are online,
but it's very difficult to track,
you know,
I mean,
it's,
it's that you have take them at their
word for it.
They eat nothing but meat for 20 years
and they feel amazing,
but there's not very many of them.
There's a,
there's a,
well,
there may be more out there,
but it's in terms of like what I've come
across articles,
um,
you know,
just a social media profiles,
people to talk about the positive
benefits of it.
It seems to me that most people that are
talking about the positive benefits are
talking about it within a one and two
year window.
That's what we're really dealing with a
lot of.
Um,
Sean Baker,
Dr Sean Baker who is probably the
leading proponent of it,
or one of the poster boys of it,
along with Jordan Peterson and his
daughter Mckayla,
a Jordan Peterson,
his daughter Mckayla.
They're different in that they were
dealing with severe autoimmune issues.
Uh,
his daughters had two joints replaced,
but before she was 18 she had her,
well she had her ankle replaced before
she was 18 and I think she had her hip
replaced shortly after that and um,
Jordan has had some pretty severe
autoimmune issues and depression within
with both of them,
those things were cleared up,
but as you've talked about multiple
times before on this show,
depression has been linked to disorders
in the gut biome.
Right.
And this is something that you feel like
may be contributing to this as long as,
as well as both of them also got very
lean.
Jordan lost a ton of weight.
He's back to the weight that he was when
he was 25 years old and I've eaten with
him and the guy eats,
he eats a lot,
but it's a lot of meat just like he'll
eat like a 30 ounce steak,
you know,
which is just crazy.
It's a crazy amount of meat.
But,
um,
I don't know how many times he's doing
that a day.
I don't know.
Yeah,
yeah,
I think I,
you know,
going back to the,
the,
the point,
it's like there are other,
you understanding the mechanisms is and
there's a lot of potential confounding
factors,
right?
And that with any anecdotal data is
extremely important to consider.
I mean,
people can't even neutral,
you know,
scientists,
nutritionists,
just people can't even agree on the best
diet because a lot of these
epidemiological and observational
studies which don't establish causation,
have an enormous amount of confounding
factors and it is freaking,
it's so hard to like control for that.
I mean just as a perfect example,
we've talked about this before on the
podcast,
but you know,
the vegetarian versus people that eat
meat,
one of the really large studies that was
done and,
and,
and Dr Valter Longo was part of that
study looked at all cause mortality and
cancer mortality and it was lower and
vegetarians,
but they decided to take the mediators
and say,
okay,
what about within this group?
The people that are healthy meat eaters
are people that are,
you know,
not,
not unhealthy.
So they're not obese.
They're not sedentary,
they're not smoking,
the not alcohol,
not excessively drinking alcohol.
Those people,
when they took out that,
those confounding factors,
the mediators had the same mortality as
a vegetarian,
same cancer.
So confounding factors are so important
and that with anything with anecdotal,
you have people that are exercising like
crazy.
Exercise is also been shown to change
microbiome,
independent of diet,
um,
in a positive way where you're actually
producing more of the bacteria that are
producing things like lactic acid.
So in fasting does the same thing.
And so you have people that are fasting.
So,
you know,
it's not like you can't do other things
if you're on that type of bed to,
to sort of help with the microbiome.
But I think again,
if there's a way you can do,
you know,
if there's a way that you can get these
benefits without having to do something.
So hyperdub restrictive and we'll talk
about.
I mean,
I have concerns for that.
We can definitely get into that.
But um,
then why not try that?
And you know,
the thing with like,
for example,
doing like a prolonged fast,
you know,
once,
once a quarter,
once every couple of months,
depending on how severe your your issues
are.
I mean there's,
there's been benefits shown with that,
like an aging,
like,
you know,
so people that have been put on this
fasting mimicking diet,
they have improved biomarkers of aging.
Um,
they increase their lean muscle mass.
I mean,
so like I said,
an animal studies and you can't directly
translate the animal studies to humans
because rodents have a really fast
metabolism and if you fast them for 48
hours,
they lose 20 percent of their body
weight where humans only losing one or
two percent.
I mean,
that's like clearly,
you know.
Yeah.
So you can't,
I mean obviously you can't completely
translate everything that's done in a
fascinating roden to humans.
But there are definitely organs are
shrinking.
And then literally we growing after the
fast is over.
Like it's like this rejuvenation
process.
And it seems as though selectively
damage cells are killed.
In fact,
this whole,
like there's a whole,
um,
Dr Valter Longo showing that cancer
cells are really,
really susceptible to dying when
they're,
when you do like a prolonged fast,
even a fasting mimicking diet,
and he's,
he's,
he's shown this an animal studies and
you send a couple of clinical studies
were,
were patients with cancer were treated
with standard of care,
but before their standard of care
treatment,
they were faster to for up to 72 hours.
And what happens,
what he shown in animal studies happens
is that because the fasting is a type of
stress,
all your healthy cells increase all
these stress response pathways.
They make more heat shock proteins.
They're increasing antioxidant
production pathways,
antiinflammatory.
They're doing all this really good stuff
in response.
Cancer cells can't do that.
They're like screwed up.
And so they can't activate the stress
response pathway.
So it ends up killing them.
So what you end up happening happening
happening is that when you're giving
another genotoxic stress like chemo or
radiation,
your healthy cells become more resistant
to the damaging effects of the
radiation.
And the cancer cells become more
sensitized to the death.
And so what he's shown him in his pilot
studies in humans is that basically,
um,
the humans that were,
that were,
that were treated with the standard of
care,
I think it was chemo and also fasted,
they had less neutropenia,
which is the loss of like neutrophils,
which is the side effect because you're
losing normal healthy cells.
So they had less of that happening,
less myelosuppression.
So I mean anyways,
the point is that I think if you can
find a way to get positive benefits,
you know,
without having to do something so risky
and potentially dangerous and unstudied,
um,
you know,
in a unstudied in a really scientific
way of controlling for contract
compounding factors and all sorts of
longterm.
I mean,
just all of that is really important.
Well then just comprehensive breakdown
that you just did is something that's
really lacking from a lot of discussion
of this carnivore diet.
And from the proponents of it,
it's almost like a lot of them are going
into it blindfolded.
They'll like,
look,
it seems to be working.
So I'm just going to stick with it.
But again,
when you're talking about most people's
cases,
you're talking about one year,
maybe two years,
sometimes even less,
where they're having these benefits and
as you're saying,
it's entirely possible that they're
setting themselves up for some potential
longterm damage.
It is.
Um,
it is definitely possible.
And again,
at the end of the day there's no data,
there's no data.
So you can say for sure,
right,
there's no data,
but I have concerns and we can talk
about those concerns for sure.
I would like to.
But you know,
the thing is understanding mechanism,
like you said,
going in blindly.
I mean you have a hypothesis and it's
like,
okay,
your hypothesis is all plants are bad.
That's what I keep hearing.
And it's like,
well that's a hypothesis,
but what about all the other things that
are potentially happening while you're
doing this diet and you're fasting more,
your microbiomes changing dramatically
changing.
And those things all have been known.
Multiple studies have shown that humans
and animals mechanistic detail to have
benefits on autoimmunity,
on aging in general,
on brain function.
I mean all sorts of things.
You know.
So it's mechanism is so important,
you have to realize that that's the
whole basis of science,
understanding how the world works around
you,
understanding how your body works,
mechanisms like you have hypothesis and
it's very,
and I understand it's like someone
experiences something positive.
It's like well this must be,
this is it,
this is the end all be all and.
But you have to realize the shits
complicated.
You got to understand the mechanism and
you may be doing something a longterm
that potentially.
I mean it really hasn't been studied.
Yes.
So.
Well that was one of the.
I mean I had Jordan's daughter Mckayla
on who's had some pretty dramatic
results from this carnivore diet,
but she's giving essentially nutrition
consulting to people,
but she doesn't really have a background
in it and she's in.
She doesn't have the information that
you just distributed,
like what you just said to all these
people listening,
the way you're describing the,
the mechanisms and the benefits of
fasting and all these different various
things that are happening inside of your
gut and all these different things that
are happening with healthy cells and
damaged cells with fasting and that this
is mimicked by this restrictive diet.
And then this is all absent from the
dialogue.
This is all absent from the dust and
this is one of the things that's
disturbing the most disturbing for me.
It's like I get that they're seeing
positive results.
I cannot deny that they're receiving,
but when they start saying,
uh,
you know,
plants are bad and there's a,
like my friend Chris,
he's always talking about the war on
carbs.
He's having real.
He's also got Chris Bell.
He's got autoimmune issues as well.
He's had both of his hips replaced
before he was 35 and you know,
severe arthritis and he is leaner than
he's ever been and benefiting greatly
from this carnivore diet.
But you know,
he's,
he's like,
he talks about,
he uses Hashtag war on carbs,
you know,
and he doesn't eat salad,
he won't eat greens.
I think Greens are bad for you.
And I'm like,
man,
I don't not sure that's correct.
I think it's so important what you're
saying.
And um,
there's a,
uh,
a researcher online that I've been in
contact with names Kevin Bass and his
bass or bass be ass,
not sure what,
how do you pronounce it?
But he also brought up this possibility
that it could be a calorie restriction
that these people are dealing with this
essentially some of the same mechanisms
that are the positive reactions from
fasting that you're,
you're dealing with here.
And I'm very happy that you're saying
the same thing.
Yeah,
I,
I think that is one very strong
possibility.
And that is something,
you know,
there's lots of hypotheses here and you
know,
given all the data and there's lots of
positive data about eating plants as
well,
you know.
So it's,
it's really hard.
That's one hypothesis and that seems to
be the one everyone's sort of
gravitating to.
Um,
you know,
if,
if someone's also wanting to reduce
their,
their glycemic load and all that,
I mean there's,
there are other,
I mean eating just a modified Paleo
Diet.
I mean I eat something like a modified
Paleo Diet where it's like I'm eating,
I'm eating fish and meat,
meat,
poultry and a lot of leafy Greens and
cruciferous vegetables.
Now you can do and nuts or you can do a
ketogenic diet.
Like they're like I just talked about
the study that was done looking at the
fasting mimicking diet and humans with
multiple sclerosis,
sclerosis.
Um,
there was uh,
the same in publishing the same paper.
There was a study they study that put
patients on Ketogenic Diet for,
I believe it was three months and it
improves symptoms of autoimmunity as
well.
Was it comparable?
Yeah,
yeah.
Improvement.
Yeah.
Interesting.
So you know,
the key to genic die a modified
ketogenic diet is also,
you know,
there's also concerns with that.
Not everyone responds very well and you
know,
the micronutrient deficiencies have been
a concern,
but you can actually eat a lot of
vegetables,
green,
a good ones that are,
that are low and glycaemic.
So my concern exactly,
my concerns are much,
much less,
um,
and it's been studied a lot more.
I mean,
at least there's been lifespan studies
in animals on ketogenic diet where it's
like improving,
you know,
the way they age,
it's improving their cognitive function,
brain aging,
extending their lifespan.
So,
you know,
if people are looking for,
in addition to wanting to like help with
their auto immunity issues,
you know,
there's also,
if it's like,
well,
I also just don't want to have a lot of
insulin response.
I want to lower my glycemic levels and
things like that.
Um,
it seems like a much better option than,
than doing something completely
unstudied.
Right.
And so,
um,
you know,
I think that's a really good place to
start and obviously not disregarding
everyone's anecdotes.
And of course there's also the placebo
and no cpl effect,
which are very real.
I mean extremely well real.
It's why a lot of drugs don't ever make
it to market is because they can't beat
placebo.
You know where it's like,
people think they're going to get a
positive response from something they
can write and the opposite is true.
People think they're going to get a
negative response for something.
They can just got to be a way to market
it.
The placebo effect in a pill form.
I think it's great.
I think so,
and what's interesting is that genetics
determines that there's snips.
Gene,
basically single nucleotide
polymorphisms where changes in the
sequence of DNA in a certain gene makes
it function a little differently.
While the gene that's really important
seems to be really important for either
whether or not you're going to have a
placebo versus no CBO isn't controls
dopamine,
the degradation of dopamine,
so people that are really likely to
placebo response have more dopamine in
their brain.
It's called comp t,
the snip and the genes called comp t.
people that have less dopamine are more
subject to the no cbo and this has been
shown in dose dependent manner in
intervention,
intervention trials,
randomized control in humans and not.
It's not a diet.
There's been studies on diet as well as
showing like no CBO effects,
so people think they have a gluten
sensitivity,
which I do think that's a real thing.
I mean I'm not saying non CELIAC gluten
sensitivity.
I think there's enough evidence that
showed that does exist.
However,
there was this great study that was
published four years ago showing people
that thought they were,
you know,
having gluten sensitivity issues.
They were,
they were randomized and none of them
were given gluten,
but they didn't know that.
They thought maybe there's a chance I'm
going to get the gluten.
I don't know I'm being randomized.
Of course they had a negative response.
They had distended bloating,
pain,
but there was no glue.
So the no cbo effect is also real and
that's something to keep in mind as
well.
If you think,
you know,
I'm going to have a bad response if I
eat these plants,
you can fit there.
Yeah,
it's definitely,
it's definitely a real thing.
I think placebos much better.
I think that's a great,
like it's a great thing that,
that exists.
Especially if you could figure out a way
to trick yourself.
You're changing dopamine levels that
affects your immune system.
I mean it affects a chiropractor who was
banking on that.
He was doing something called zone
healing and the more I pressed him on
this,
the more he basically said,
well,
if you believe that it works,
I'm like,
okay,
so you're saying that it doesn't work
unless you tricked this person into
believing that it works,
so you're a trickster is what you're
doing.
He didn't want to go that far,
but that's essentially,
there's no real scientific basis to this
idea that you press on someone's back
and fix the thyroid.
I absolutely think that placebo accounts
for a lot of that stuff.
Yeah.
And again,
Reiki,
all that shit,
all of it.
And I think that um,
the,
the genetic snips involved really they
do play a role.
Is there a diet that increases dopamine
because there's.
You can increase serotonin with htp and
to fan which converts to htp five htp
what is.
Is there anything that ramps up your
dope?
You know,
what does in the prefrontal cortex is
fish oil.
In fact,
schizophrenia,
patients are prescribed a really high
dose because they,
they lack,
they're doping means lower and the
prefrontal Cortex,
and this is sort of associated with a
lot of the negative paranoid,
delusional sort of.
When you say high dose,
what are you talking about?
Oh,
like six grand.
Three.
Anywhere between three to six grams a
day.
And what does a normal dose?
Well,
if you look at,
if you're talking about normal in the
sense where what's typically used in
like a randomized controlled trial,
it's like one,
one,
one or two grams.
What is recommended?
People like Usta or what would you
recommend?
Like there's no recommended nothing.
It's not now because because what's
recommended is the.
So there's a plant version of it,
Alpha linoleic acid,
because you can convert that into the
marina,
the marina omega three fatty acids,
Dha and EPA.
Uh,
that's the one that's recommended,
so it's like the,
what you essentially need,
right?
So,
so that's the one that's recommended,
but they were concern about
potential heavy metal poisonings when
you're taking in fish oil or is that
all,
all that stuff?
Do they know how to filter that stuff
out?
It's definitely purified out and I mean
it depends on the fish,
the fish while you're getting your,
your fish oil from.
But there's,
there's,
there's um,
international fish oil standards
organization.
Uh,
there's a lot of different fish oil
companies,
um,
are tested by them and they show their,
all their arsenic,
mercury,
pcbs and dioxins,
like all those,
you know,
potentially harmful compounds.
And they also look at oxidized
polyunsaturated fatty acids for the
looking at total oxidation and things
like that.
So that's a really good site to use to
look at whether,
you know,
your fish oil brand is
years in the pill form or do you do like
Carlson's where you get in the bottle
and take spoonfuls of it?
So I get mine in the pill form because I
have a friend that makes it in Norway
and he sort of has convinced me that
it's really good.
So I really liked his fish oil and he
doesn't make it in the liquid form.
Um,
but I do.
So I take,
I take about like five or six grams a
day.
I take a lot.
Wow.
Five or six grams.
Yeah.
And I'm taking like a high dose Dha
because um,
it gets into breast milk and I haven't
100 percent.
When did my son just yet?
How many pills is five or six grams?
Um,
it's like,
oh,
that I take.
So I'm taking six,
six pills.
The pills or grant?
Yeah.
Wow.
So,
um,
that is high dose.
It's really high dose.
It's really,
it's really good.
Fisher.
It's not,
he,
it,
he's working on getting it available in
the United States.
Uh,
I think that's supposed to happen like
in the next couple of months.
But um,
I used to take Carlson's Carlson's was a
bottle.
Yeah,
that's what I take.
Yeah.
Because you take a lot,
right?
Yeah.
So,
yeah.
But I'll take three tablespoons.
I thought that was a lot.
How much is in wondering idea?
We'll have to talk about my,
my Alzheimer's will make it three
publication that we still have time.
Carnivores stuff.
Let's keep going.
I'll put that aside because I actually
have a good friend whose dad has
Alzheimer's and I sent her your clip
from your instagram from yesterday.
Oh,
cool.
About that too.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah,
we will.
I'll send you my paper.
It was just accepted.
Um,
and uh,
it should be out online this month,
late sometime this month.
But um,
okay.
So,
My potential concerns with carnivore
diet,
um,
you know,
I think,
I'm sure,
I mean I know this,
I've seen it all over the blogosphere,
is that,
you know,
the,
the micronutrients and you know,
they don't really matter.
They're rda is,
weren't set for carnivores and all this,
all this stuff that I've read.
But I think to start out like
understanding,
you know,
micro nutrients are essential about 30
vitamins and minerals that are really
important.
They,
they do run our metabolism,
they are involved in making
neurotransmitters.
They're involved in,
you know,
pulling calcium out of our arteries and
Brittany tour bones,
they're involved in all sorts of things.
People when they hear the word
metabolism,
they always just think about,
you know,
food you eat,
it's like metabolism refers to a lot of
things.
And there's about 22,
I'm sorry,
there's 22 percent of all your enzymes
in your body require a micronutrient to
function.
Um,
and this is repairing damage from Dna,
all sorts of things really important.
Um,
and so there's about 30 of them that are
essentially you have to get them for
your diet because you don't make them in
your body and if you don't get them from
your diet,
it can lead to health problems and death
actually.
So,
so that's,
that's kind of,
you know,
what micronutrients are Rda.
So recommended dietary allowance,
um,
those have been set,
a variety of different studies are used.
So there's randomized controlled trials,
non randomized controlled trials,
there's depletion,
depletion studies,
there's balance studies.
Looking at how much,
how long,
how much of a micronutrient it takes
before you start reading it.
Um,
there's cross sectional studies and
there's case studies and this is a
collaboration between the United States
and Canada and some European countries
as well.
So a lot of experiments are done to,
to figure out the recommended dietary
allowance.
The first thing that's done is the,
the estimated average wreck,
the s e a ear,
um,
intake.
So that is done by basically looking at
any population and going,
okay,
how much of this micronutrient do we
need?
So that 50 percent of the population has
adequate levels,
the other 50 percent will be deficient.
So like there's a bell curve.
And so it's like literally in the middle
of the bell curve and then the RDA is
set from that two standard deviations
above.
And it's supposed to make about 97 point
five percent of the population gets
enough.
So that's how the Rda set for each
micronutrient.
It's different than the experiments are
done,
are different to look at them.
So there's a few concerns,
of course,
with an all meat diet with particular
micronutrients,
because you know,
there's a lot of,
you know,
certain micronutrients that are
concentrated in meat and there's a lot
that are concentrated in plants and you
can find some of the ones that are more
concentrated in meat in plants,
most in most cases,
um,
but it's much better to get it from the
meat and implants.
There's,
it's much more concentrated,
you know,
and you can find it in some amounts in
meat,
but it's much,
you know,
it's a lot easier to get it from plants.
So,
uh,
one of the,
of course,
the micronutrients that the concern is
the vitamin C,
of course,
right?
That's,
that's the one that everyone talks
about.
So vitamin C is a really important
cofactor for what that means as cofactor
just means that it's binds to an enzyme
and helps it work.
It's important for making Collagen.
It's important for converting dopamine
into norepinephrine,
which is important for that,
you know,
flight or flight response.
Um,
it plays a role in,
and I'm making carnitine which is
important for using fatty acids for,
it's for energy.
Um,
and then of course an antioxidant.
It also plays a really important role
in,
in neutrophils.
Their neutrophils are a type of immune
cell when they're activated,
when you have any sort of bacterial
exposure,
um,
virus,
uh,
things that can even come from the gut,
you know,
like Lps,
we get from dead bacteria that are dying
in the gut.
Neutrophils get activated and they soak
up vitamin C because they release a
bunch of hydrogen peroxide which damages
the neutrophil itself.
And so the vitamin C's sort of prevents
that from happening,
uh,
plays a really important role in cell
cell integrity and things like that.
So the,
the um,
there's a variety of ways and vitamin C
is transported into the cell.
And I see a reading on the Internet,
a little bit of misunderstanding.
People following the carnivore diet seem
to think that because they're not
getting any,
uh,
their glucose levels are low,
that they're getting more vitamin C in.
So,
so vitamin C,
I'm also called ascorbic acid.
A goes between two different states or
scorebig acid is the reduced form which
has the antioxidant form.
It goes also into an oxidized form,
so it's kind of going back and forth.
It goes through about four cycles of
that,
the oxidized form,
it's called dehydroascorbic acid,
and there's two ways that you transport
vitamin C,
you absorb it to the gut.
Epithelial cells is transported into a
variety of tissues in the body.
Ascorbic acid goes through sodium
dependent vitamin C transporters.
Those are not dependent on glucose.
There's no competition for glucose.
The that's,
that's how vitamin C gets into the cell,
and most cells actually transport
vitamin C in that form with the
exception of red blood cells,
which don't have that transporter.
They use another transporter called
glucose transporters or glute,
and that one does.
Glucose does compete.
Interestingly,
dehydroascorbic acid binds much better.
Uh,
it's actually slightly more by binds to
the transporter.
Then I'm glucose.
But in conditions like,
um,
hyperglycemia,
like type one or type two diabetics,
they actually don't get vitamin C into
the red blood cells and it leads to like
vascular problems and stuff like that.
So,
so,
um,
it's an interesting hypothesis that
maybe if you're having,
you know,
less of a,
um,
your blood glucose levels are really
bottomed out.
Maybe there maybe that there's some
salvage pathway,
you're able to help get vitamin C in the
oxidized form is going in some other
cells that usually doesn't go in or
whatever,
something like that.
It's an interesting hypothesis,
which is there's no data on,
right.
But the experiments that were done to
choose the rda for vitamin C,
we're done,
um,
the,
the more recent rda so that it changed
back in like two that after 2000 or 2001
or something,
it's about 90 milligrams a day for men
and 75 for women,
they were,
they were depletion repletion studies.
So men were,
were given about less than five
milligrams a day of vitamin C,
you die with their diet.
And this was about a six months to
study.
There were in a metabolic ward.
And,
um,
it was determined that it was kind of
unsafe to keep,
to keep going.
So,
so basically they started the repletion
where they started giving,
uh,
the,
these men,
vitamin C at different doses and a
vitamin C follows like a sigmoidal s
curve.
So once you kind of deplete someone in
their vitamin C,
when you give them,
for example,
30 milligrams,
it isn't really enough to kind of go,
it doesn't really raise plasma levels
much.
You have to get up to 100.
Once you get up to 100,
then you actually start to excrete
vitamin C.
But before that you're just,
your body's holding onto everything or
not excluding anything.
Two hundred milligrams was a maximum
bioavailability.
And then after that,
um,
you start to decrease bioavailability.
New York screening a lot of identity.
So the,
the new.
So the scientists that published this
paper,
Mark Levine at the Nih,
um,
recommended that the RDA be set at 200
milligrams,
but it was set at 90,
which is literally right before you
start to excrete,
which was 100 milligrams.
That data,
along with the neutrophil data,
there were some neutrophil data that was
looked at.
Um,
you know,
how much vitamin C was it important to.
Because neutrophil sop it up to prevent
that hydrogen peroxide induced damage.
And so that's kind of how the RJ was
said.
I'm now the question is in any,
with any Rga,
like,
you know,
the important thing to consider is well
the rds are set to prevent acute
disease,
but what about promoting optimal health?
You know,
like that's really important.
Like how much are these micronutrients
you need throughout our lifespan to,
to,
you know,
to maintain optimal health and age.
Well,
so this is something that's really
important because a lot of enzymes that
require micronutrient for preventing
short term disease,
something that can kill you.
Like there's also enzymes that are
required to prevent,
you know,
things that are associated with aging,
like DNA damage.
So if there's only so much of a
micronutrient around which,
where's it gonna go,
is it going to go where the,
you know,
is it going to prevent any damage which
doesn't make a difference until five or
six decades later?
Or is it gonna make sure you live on to
pass on your genes and you know,
reproduce.
And so,
um,
my former postdoctoral mentor,
Dr Bruce Ames,
proposed this whole and he has published
a couple of foundational papers
supporting this idea,
which he calls the triage theory.
So he's saying that basically he thinks
actually a lot of our days are too low
and that,
you know,
optimal rdas will account for how much
is needed for these longterm functions.
So that's really important to consider
with the vitamin C,
um,
you know,
it's,
it's really a small amount that's needed
to,
to be used as a cofactor for,
you know,
an enzyme for Collagen production and
you actually don't need that much.
And it was done like studies were done
years and years ago with that
established like 10 milligrams of
vitamin C was enough to prevent scurvy,
which can happen when you're basically,
you don't have enough vitamin C for,
for college and production.
And,
um,
and even that's kind of questionable
because back at the time when those
studies were done,
it was before really good analytical
essays were available.
So,
you know,
the asset that was done to measure,
um,
various things were,
it was lots of things could confound,
so it may even be less,
maybe more,
maybe less.
It's kind of not known.
So,
um,
you know,
that,
that is something to consider as well as
the fact that basically there's a lot of
biological variation with vitamin C
requirements and this has been shown in
other animals that also require vitamin
C,
like Guinea pigs.
So like if you take 100 Guinea pigs and
this is published back in the sixties or
seventies,
um,
like there was like 10 fold variation in
how much each of them required vitamin C
they required even though they were
given like,
wow.
Yeah.
So tenfold.
Tenfold.
Yeah.
So there's huge variation in the half
life of vitamin C and in their
transporters.
And so this has been shown in rodents as
well.
Rodin's make vitamin C and their liver.
But the same thing has been shown.
And actually back when this,
the European sailors were getting scurvy
and dying of it,
only about 50 percent.
Only about half of those dealers got
scurvy.
The other 50 percent didn't have any
symptoms,
presumably because not getting scurvy.
That's what I'm saying.
I'm saying that,
you know,
for one it doesn't take much.
Right.
Or getting some of it from me.
Yeah.
And so,
so the thing,
you know,
it,
it doesn't take much to,
to maintain the enzymatic function of
some of the,
some of the enzymes involved in making
Collagen and that,
you know,
so it doesn't take much for that.
But the question is about what about,
you know,
all the host of all the factors and the
neutrophils and um,
you know,
your body stores like orders of
magnitude more vitamin C than then than
it needs for that,
for the,
for its function as a cofactor.
And it's like why does it do that?
Is it just because maybe during scarce
food scarcity you want and wants to make
sure it has enough or is there are,
you know,
the antioxidant functions and other
functions really important or other
unknown functions.
So I think the vitamin C,
you know,
there are certainly,
getting enough to prevent scurvy and
there could be biological variation in
that as well.
Right?
You don't need much to prevent scurvy in
the junior.
You're dealing with a very small sample
size.
You don't know how many people are
actually on this or supplementing,
right?
How many of them are supplementing and
why wouldn't they be right.
Yeah,
exactly.
Um,
when you think that a lot of these
issues could be prevented with just
multivitamin and supplementation.
Well,
I mean,
I think the best thing is to get it from
food and we'll talk through it.
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
so the,
the,
there's another one that's potentially
risky and that is vitamin E,
which kind of vitamin D helps recycle
vitamin C and vitamin C helps recycle
vitamin E and vitamin e actually,
um,
most people think of as an antioxidant,
which it does,
it prevents a lot of oxidative chains.
It's kind of breaks the chain of
oxidation,
but also is really important for
maintaining cell integrity.
And that's how the Rda was chosen for
that one.
So,
um,
how does it do that?
So it's important for inside the cell
membrane,
so it's,
uh,
it's important antioxidant inside the
cell membrane and so it's preventing a
lot of oxidative factors that are
happening just from normal metabolism,
normal,
what's happening.
You and I are doing it right now,
a DNA damage that damage our DNA.
It also damages the Lipitz in our,
in our cell membranes.
And so,
and so vitamin E,
it plays a really important role in the
integrity of it.
And so,
um,
the experiments that were done for
choosing the RDA for vitamin E,
we're two and a half years long and um,
men were given three milligrams of
vitamin E,
so the RDA is 15 milligrams.
So they were given three and after two
and a half years they started getting
hemolysis of the red blood cells because
they're red blood cell.
Um,
the membranes of the red blood cells
weren't being maintained very well.
After two and a half it took two and a
half years.
It's a long time for,
you know,
for this to show up.
And so,
um,
for whatever reason,
it was decided that having hemo license
happen lower than 12 percent is okay,
12 percent was the cutoff.
And so they,
when they did the depletion studies,
it was 15,
it was actually 12 milligrams and then
for the ear and they went up two
standard deviations and found 15.
Basically the RDA was at 15.
So the question becomes,
well right,
so vitamin D you can,
you know,
you can get some vitamin E if you're
eating some egg yolks and butter and if
you're eating some fish but you're not
going to,
it's really hard to get 15 milligrams
from,
from those sources.
And,
and then if you're eating that,
what about all the other stuff you have
to eat to get your other,
you know,
so it is a good source of nuts are
really,
really the best source.
Like almonds,
like 100 grand,
100 grams of almonds with like give you
your rda.
Really good source.
Um,
so,
uh,
so the question becomes,
well,
okay,
you know,
what happens if I'm only getting seven
milligrams a day,
is it going to take,
you know,
six or seven or eight years before my
cell membrane integrity is compromised
more,
you know,
what you know.
So it's just,
there's a lot of important questions to
think about,
you know,
and it's like these rdas I would even
argue they're set too low in some cases
where you're really trying to just
prevent things like that are like
hemolysis,
lysis of the red blood cells.
And so what about all these other
longterm effects?
Um,
you know,
enzymes that are involved in DNA repair
for example.
And another one would be like fully a
full eight.
You can get if you eat,
if you're eating like 150 grams of
cooked beef liver every day.
But like who does that?
You know,
I mean,
and if you're not doing that and you're
eating,
you got to eat like you're 48 starting
to get your vitamin E and you've got,
you know,
so it's like,
it's not easy.
And I'm not saying you can't get,
you know,
some amounts of it,
but you may not be getting the RDA.
And so foliate plays a very important
role in actually making new DNA,
you know,
if you don't have full eight,
you essentially incorporate something
from rna called Eurocell into DNA and
all your like Dna polymerases and stuff.
We're cruising along and see and then
make a nick in the DNA and it literally,
you know,
it's a,
it's a nick,
it's like uh,
in your,
in your DNA.
And if you have it,
DNA is double stranded.
It's,
we have it on two ends,
the DNA,
what you do,
because it's really important to make
one of the nucleotides timing.
Then you know,
you're going to have a double stranded
break.
And actually my former postdoctoral
mentor,
Dr Bruce Ames,
published a study showing that if you
take animals and um,
make them deficient in full eight or
give them really,
really low levels of full late,
it causes strands and their dna just
like being irradiated.
Like he compared them side by side.
It was east exact same thing.
And then he published a study that was
with humans showing that actually humans
that are getting really low levels of
full late also had a certain type of DNA
damage called micro nuclei.
You know.
So the question is,
well,
you know,
if I,
if I'm getting only so much fully,
you know,
is,
is it something happening to my dna,
my getting strand breaks.
The same goes for magnesium.
I mean,
you can get magnesium if you're eating,
you know,
this,
it's just been,
what about the day?
And then what about the bottom e?
But you know,
so it's really hard.
It's really hard,
uh,
to,
to do that.
And Dna damage,
that's something you can't measure it.
You're not going to go.
Your Lipid panel isn't going to tell you
that there's no consumer test available.
There was a few years ago with a startup
tried doing it,
but it's really hard because there's,
if you're sending blood samples to a lab
to be tested for DNA damage.
I have done many dna damage experiments
on humans.
So clinical studies.
I was involved in Dr Ames lab.
Um,
and I've done studies,
kinetic studies where we took blood out
of a patient measure DNA damage
immediately or frozen down,
or we let it sit on a bench for 30
minutes,
two hours,
four hours overnight after two hours,
all the tons of DNA damage that had come
up because it's being exposed to the
oxygen and all that is I'm creating
basically DNA damage.
So anyways,
the point is,
is that DNA damage isn't something
you're going to measure.
You don't feel it and you're not going
to feel it.
I mean,
it's happening in us right now.
We don't know how many,
but it is.
We have enzymes that are repairing that
damage and those enzymes require
magnesium.
We're getting enough folate to make sure
that that damage isn't happening.
And again,
you can get a good amount of full liver
is one of the best is really great
source,
but you have to eat it every day and you
have to like,
you know,
I guess 150 grams of livers,
not that much,
but you have to eat it every day,
you know.
Um,
so it's,
it's just really important to consider
these,
you know,
the fact that these micronutrients are
important,
they have longterm effects.
I mean the two and a half years it took
to show the hemo license and red blood
cells two and a half years.
So what happens if you're getting a
modest amount,
not quite three milligrams,
but you're getting twice that or maybe
you're getting nine,
you know,
what happens seven years from now,
like you don't know it's in.
It's important that your health is
important.
So I think that.
So those,
you know,
and there's a variety of other magazines
you can also get if you're eating a lot
of like a stomach lining tripe.
So it's called [inaudible].
Yeah.
I mean,
so it's not like you can't get it,
but they're not.
Most of these people that are carnivore
diet or just eating beef,
right?
Especially if the people are working a
job where they go in to an office nine
to five or they're traveling and it's a
really hard to eat all this cool.
Like,
you know,
the,
the inuits were eating things like raw,
like they were eating raw liver,
Raul,
like raw whale blubber and spleen
spleen's a good source.
I mean you can get vitamin C from
spleen,
I think heart.
So there's some organs,
vitamin C when you cook it,
25 percent of it's lost.
So that's why a lot of the muscle meat
and stuff,
it does start out with vitamin C,
but when you cook it,
I mean if you're not eating it raw,
then you're definitely,
it's negligible.
One young guy who is a carnivore diet
proponent that seems to be approaching
this in a much more comprehensive way.
He's really big on organ meats in
particular,
liver and many other things.
And he's talking about how these organ
meats,
uh,
will,
be excellent sources of a lot of the
vitamins that people are concerned that
you're missing from vegetables.
You're,
do you think that that is possible?
And it means spleen,
I guess for vitamin C.
But like what?
Uh,
what about just liver or kidneys or
things along those lines?
Mean what,
what are you going to be deficient in?
If you go the organ meat route,
I mean I think that,
you know,
if you're the,
the magnesium and um,
uh,
the magazine won't be in while you're
out there.
Can you give me another one who's.
Thanks,
I'm magnesium,
but you can get.
I mean it's,
you can do it right.
I mean you can do it,
but um,
it seems very difficult and I don't
think most people will do it.
And you recommend of course,
getting all this stuff from food.
If you were going to get magnesium,
but it did.
Is it feasible that you could just
supplement with multivitamins and,
and cover all your bases?
You know what I mean?
I think the same goes for Vegetarians.
I think they should,
you know,
they do supplement and they take the 12,
they take iron,
which isn't necessarily.
I think it's much better to take iron,
get iron from food.
It's not as bioavailable in a pill form.
Also,
the Bible belt,
the pill form has been shown to disrupt
other things like,
whereas iron from food isn't just
depends on the ratios of other things
like,
you know,
disrupting,
disrupting the transport of other
transition elements and things like
that.
It's isolated also.
Yeah,
something about that.
Also there's bacteria in the gut that
um,
that can be pathogenic and that use
iron,
but it seems to be only in supplemental
form that that's.
I'm not saying you should never
supplement supplement iron throughout
my,
uh,
third trimester,
but I just think that you're going to
potentially run into more problems.
Um,
with that,
you know,
iron does it.
It does come from bread,
meat,
correct.
Yeah,
I mean irons very bioavailable when it's
bound to hemoglobin and versus
vegetarians just ate red meat.
You know,
there's,
I think that,
that there's a whole other host of
micronutrients that vegetarians are
there,
but that's not what we're talking about.
So I think,
you know,
um,
there's also other important reasons to
eat the plants instead of doing just the
organ meat and also just doing the
supplements as well,
you know,
in some of those reasons have to do with
the fact that microbiome is really
important.
So you're getting,
you know,
the fermentable types of fiber that are
really important for growing all sorts
of commensal bacteria in the gut.
Like we don't know what's gonna happen
with,
you know,
someone that's only just eating meat
longterm,
particularly with,
like I said,
the putrifactive bacteria and all that.
I mean that's just a word future future
Fi.
Yeah,
that's the Fed feathers.
Putrifactive bacteria also that are like
on corpses and stuff.
In fact,
that's where I think the cadaveric comes
from the work they produce something
evergreen,
right?
That's what I'm thinking.
It must be where it should have a huge
chip and cadaveric mean.
Sounds,
sounds like farts.
So I was like,
they actually are.
Yeah,
they do the portrait.
I think there's a response with some of
the really nasty parts.
Um,
but you know,
like that.
So that's another reason.
And then the other,
the other important thing,
or the phytochemicals,
the,
there's these polyphenols and all these
things that are present in plant the
humans were,
we evolved eating,
we evolved eating them,
you know,
so,
so the,
the,
it's during,
throughout human evolution,
you know,
humans,
we're stressed on many levels.
One,
they went through moments of food
scarcity where the fasting came in.
I mean,
that's important right now.
We don't have that.
We can get food all the time,
anytime,
right?
So,
so that was an important,
um,
uh,
stress that humans have evolved with
exercise aerobic exercise,
right?
That's another thing.
I mean,
you had to,
you had to move to get food and run from
predators.
I mean,
so we,
we evolved exercising.
Now you can see so many people don't do
that.
We also evolved eating plants and meat.
I mean,
we're omnivores.
So we have these basically all these
pathways that are activated when we eat
plants and from certain compounds in
plants into insect Antifa,
Eden's,
their,
their implants.
And when humans eat them,
they basically activate a variety of
really,
really important stress response
pathways.
A lot of these pathways get activated by
exercise and fasting as well,
so there is a lot of overlap between
them,
but I see a lot of people,
you know,
on the,
on this carnivore diet,
talking about how they're so bad for you
and if they would take the time to
actually read studies,
human studies where people are given a
lot of these insect antifa didn't
compounds things like I said thiocyanate
like Sulforaphane,
I'm curcumin,
resveratrol,
anthocyanins,
and just tons and tons of them,
you know,
they would see that there's beneficial
effects that happen and there's a lot of
mechanism for why that is,
you know,
so I mean the Sulforaphane is one that I
like to talk about and there are,
there's tons and tons of human
intervention data where people are given
either cruciferous vegetables or they're
given Broccoli sprouts.
Broccoli sprouts are really great
source,
cruciferous vegetables,
Broccoli,
cabbage,
fermented cabbage,
Brussel sprouts,
you know,
all that stuff.
So Broccoli sprouts have like 10,
anywhere between 10 and 100 times more.
A lot of that work was done by Dr Jed
Fahy,
friend of mine,
he's at Johns Hopkins,
very great scientist,
as a lot of research on sulforaphane.
But,
um,
you know,
if you look at intervention trials,
we were talking about air pollution,
like there's an intervention trial.
There's more than one showing in humans
showing that if you give humans Broccoli
sprout extract for seven days,
they start to excrete benzene and
accurately and Benzenes in air
pollution.
Sixty percent on day one.
Like they started screening it in their
urine,
like you're getting rid of that.
And that's largely because sulforaphane
activates a variety of enzymes,
one called phase two detoxification
enzymes,
which are important for getting rid of a
potentially harmful compounds.
It inactivates phase one
biotransformation enzymes,
which are enzymes that are able to like
take a pro carcinogen and turn it into a
carcinogen.
So,
um,
you know,
there's intervention trials in humans
that it's,
you know,
men that were given Broccoli sprout
extract,
a lowered their,
their,
their biomarker for prostate cancer,
um,
by,
by like 86 percent or lower the doubling
rate of about 86 percent.
You know,
so this is like,
this is important.
There's studies showing that humans
given,
for example,
two different studies showing that
humans given 300 grams of Brussel
sprouts a day.
One,
they increase a really important
antioxidant in their plasma called
glutathione by like one point four fold
and they decreased oxidative DNA damage
in their blood cells.
Dna damage like we were just talking
about,
they decreased it like by 30 percent or
something like that.
Two separate studies,
Brussel sprouts and I liked,
I see people like,
you know,
I'm talking about the carnivore diet and
how sulforaphane increases DNA damage
and they like referenced this in vitro
study where they dumped sulforaphane on
cultured cells in a dish.
It's like,
you know,
what else is going to do that shit
heterocyclic amines from the cooked meat
you're eating like you know,
so.
So if you dump something at a high
enough concentration,
yeah,
it's going to fuck it up,
you know,
but we're talking about humans
ingesting.
If you were to exercise nonstop and not
rest,
it would be toxic.
If you were to fast and not stop,
Like,
you know,
so,
so how some of these pathways are
working is that they,
the dose that they're given,
you know,
eating,
it's almost impossible to,
to eat the kind of dose that it would
take to cause severe damage and you
know,
what you would get sick,
you would know,
you'd be like,
wait a minute.
Like so.
So I mean I think that using that as an
excuse is really,
um,
first of all,
they should read the studies and there's
so many more studies.
It's been shown recently to increase
gludethyon in the brain.
Human intervention studies,
humans that were given sulforaphane
extract,
increase it in their plasma and in their
brain.
Gludethyon was one of the major and Alex
in the brain plays a major role in
traumatic brain injury,
brain aging.
I mean this is important.
Like this is a possible therapeutic
intervention.
It's been shown in randomized placebo
controlled trials to improve autistic
symptoms and adolescents open label
trials.
It's been shown to improve autism in
children,
autistic symptoms,
children.
I mean,
there's just study after study after
study and I'm just talking about the
human ones and there's more,
there's also lots of animal studies
where they're feeding a mega doses and,
and there's positive benefits.
There's been studies,
you know,
feeding,
feeding humans,
large doses like something equivalent to
like 70 or 100 grams of Broccoli
sprouts,
which have a lot more so for her fame
than like Brussels sprouts do.
And there was no toxic side effects in
the liver.
Thyroid.
That's one concern people do have if you
have hyperthyroid.
Sulforaphane can compete with iodine for
transport into the thyroid.
I don't think that's usually an issue.
It certainly doesn't seem to be an issue
in healthy people,
but iodine is found in seafood.
I mean their sources of iodine you can
eat.
So maybe someone with hyperthyroid might
want to make sure they're not eating a
ton.
Like you're not like know Kale smoothie
after kills me with the other kids.
Don't be like me,
you know,
make sure you know,
just that you're having your Brussels
sprouts with your,
with your elk meat or whatever.
You know,
I think it's a problem.
Um,
so you know,
it,
I do get a little,
I see,
I see.
Like you mentioned Dr Sean Baker.
He's like,
he put out a video about like he
mentioned to me,
my name's talking about how I only talk
about in vitro data and I'm like,
dude,
go watch my video or my interview with
the expert at Johns Hopkins.
We're talking about human studies.
The in vitro data is coming from what
the opposite that had the damaging
effects.
It's in vitro dumping.
Get on the culture side.
Just two things going on.
There's one,
there's a real cursory examination of
data.
Were they in this confirmation bias and
it's the combination of the two of those
things.
They find one thing that's sort of kind
of vaguely supports what they wanted to
support and then they run with it and
they talk about it as if they're
experts.
Very dangerous.
Yes.
And this is one of the reasons why I'm
so happy that you're talking about this
because you can give people a real
comprehensive understanding of all the
different things at play.
And one of the things that I get from
you when I talked to you about nutrition
is it's mind boggling how many different
factors are going on simultaneously in
the human body when it comes to
nutrition absorption,
when,
uh,
you know,
in the various stages of the body and
how it can vary with different people
when there's so much going on.
So when someone just starts talking
about vegetables are toxic,
like,
oh,
Jesus Christ,
read any of the study,
have you just go look at the scientific
data like on it to
be toxic?
This is what's crazy.
It's,
this is an,
that's akin to veganism.
It's really,
it's a,
just another side of the same mindset.
It's almost like a religious mindset.
They hashtag.
I did say it,
look,
I'm a fucking mediator.
You can't accuse me of being anti meat,
but I,
I side,
I eat more vegetables.
I think that I eat meat.
I certainly.
It's certainly like right up there and
I'm not giving them up.
I think that's stupid.
I just did.
Doesn't make any sense to me.
And I liked them.
There's this,
there's this weird push and the,
you know,
if you look under Hashtag meet heels,
there's all these people telling these
stories about all the lost all this
weight and they did all this,
this blah blah blah and the health
benefits and Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
But they only want it to be because of
the consumption of meat only they think
that it's because of the singular aspect
of their diet and the fact that they've
eliminated everything else,
but they're not,
they don't do any studying of
elimination diets.
They don't do any study of the prolonged
benefits of fasting and all these
different things that you're talking
about,
which I think are there.
These are all factors in this really
complicated thing that's going on that
most likely has something to do with
their gut biome and their immune system.
Right?
Absolutely.
I mean those are two major confounding
factors like,
so major,
you know,
it's um,
it's important.
It's just important to approach this
like a science,
you know,
and,
and not like a religion,
like you said,
where you want to believe something.
And so you just find,
you know,
this,
this study that I also see circulating
around that why plants are really bad to
eat.
It's like they're there,
they're there means that the insect anti
nutrients or pesticides from my former
mentor.
Okay,
Dr Bruce Ames who spent his entire
career like advocating micronutrients
from vegetables and from me and from
fish.
Okay.
It's like so ironic,
but if you actually read the paper,
not only does it say it doesn't,
you know,
these,
these insect antifa like sulforaphane
don't cause cancer,
but it also has a whole section on
heterocyclic amines from cooked meat.
So if you really want to use that paper
as an argument why to not eat plants,
then maybe read the paper and realize,
oh,
it's also talking about heterocyclic
amines as well.
The point of the paper was like,
I'm getting a little emotional.
I like it.
The point of your robot self appointed
the paper was basically not to worry
about like some of the amounts that
you're being exposed to you with some of
these natural,
you know,
an insect antifa edits that are found in
plants.
And some of the cook things and meet and
as well as some of the pesticides that
are found synthetic pesticides because
basically that they're in such small
amounts that,
so that was Kinda the point of the paper
was back in the nineties.
Um,
and,
but I just think that it's a little
hypocritical to use paper,
you know,
as a,
as like.
And literally it's like,
I mean,
it's like proliferated everywhere.
That's.
I see this paper all the time.
Say Well did you read the paper because
it has a whole section on,
um,
on the insect antibiotics from coffee,
which a lot of people drink.
And also for me,
what,
there's that thing that people do where
they do have A.
I have a joke about it in my act about a
register,
a study that said that sperm can cure
depression in women.
And I slammed my laptop shut and I
didn't read another word.
I'm like,
I've found the cure,
but this is me.
This is what the title.
Yeah.
This is essentially what these people
were doing.
They,
they,
they will read or risk oftentimes don't
even read,
but recite from someone else's,
reciting it in a video didn't read
right,
which is what's going on with a lot of
this stuff and this is what I'm
concerned with.
I keep seeing all these people like,
Hey,
I'm going to try the carnivore die.
try the carnivore diet.
I tell you,
it's amazing and I'm just sitting here
shaking my head.
I'm like,
this doesn't make any sense.
Like,
I don't.
Why would you want to eliminate a
massive source of bioavailable
nutrients?
Like,
and then when they're talking about the
negative consequences of consuming
vegetables,
that there's different sort of toxic
elements.
I do remember you talking about how
these stressors can actually have a
positive and beneficial result when your
body reacts to these stressors.
Yeah,
that's exactly how exercise works.
That's exactly a fasting works exactly
how heat stress from the sauna work.
And it's how these phytochemicals.
I'm calling phytochemicals just as like
a generic category,
but they're are these compounds that are
made by plants to ward off insects.
Um,
and,
uh,
and we evolved eating them and they
activate amazing stress response
pathways in,
in humans,
in our brain,
you know,
in multiple in blood cells.
I mean,
it's just human intervention trials
showing this.
So you're going gonna miss out.
We evolved with,
we're supposed to be stressed by
exercise,
by fasting during the time restricted
eating like that.
We're supposed to do that and we're
supposed to eat some plants I think
they're trying to accomplish.
They're trying to simplify something
that's incredibly complicated and
they're doing it with this sort of
religious fervor is,
is,
it's very strange and I can feel it when
I talk about it where people get upset,
they're getting upset at me,
like I'm criticizing Jesus or something
very weird.
And again,
I'm not a Vegan.
I eat lots of meat.
You know,
you and I have had conversations about
the importance of meat.
Yeah.
So it's,
it's,
it's a religious thing.
It really is.
It's the same sort of mindset that
allows people to get by just rabidly
republican or anything else like fill in
the blanks,
whatever it is.
You know,
there was a,
there's a,
it's just a thing that people do theirs
for the longest.
There's two different camps in Jujitsu
when you're something crazy,
there's g and Nogi a gooey is the
Kimono,
this white or you know,
multicolor,
you could wear it,
different colors now,
but it started out with why and um,
a lot of people learn their Jujitsu,
grabbing onto the geek,
you know,
like sort of a Judogi or uh,
Karate d and utilizing it as part of the
grappling technique.
And then Nogi came along and would Nogi
is they use rash guards,
they don't grab the clothes and they
concentrate on control of the body with
under hooks and over hooks and gable
grips and things along those lines.
And it became a religious battle between
D and Nogi.
And I remember sitting there watching
this and it was a problem because like
people would get angry.
What camp are you in,
Bro?
And I trained both.
I have a black belt in,
I have a black belt Nogi.
I trained both of them.
I think there's benefits to both of
them,
but there was this weird thing where you
were supposed to choose sides.
It's since alleviated and people realize
how preposterous it is,
but for a long time,
like four years,
the Jujitsu community was split where
people were angry at people who are the
gate or angry at people who were no gay.
Like my friend Eddie,
Eddie Bravo who teaches no gay people
were angry at him for teaching a system
of Jujitsu that didn't involve a certain
type of clothing.
It's the same mindset.
People just want you to believe what
they believe only and they get rabid
about it.
They get crazy and I'm seeing this with
this carnivore diet and I think there's
a psychological aspect of it to it that
you were talking about when in terms of
this placebo effect that I think they
feel like I've never felt better.
I'm on this carnivore diet.
I'm doing chin ups.
I'm running around the block.
Like when you read about everyone
feeling better and I want in,
I want to on this carnivore diet,
and then there's also.
Well,
if you are doing this as opposed to the
standard American diet,
I think you have the same sort of
response that you have when people are
talking about the positive benefits of
the Vegan Diet.
I think if you have a Po,
if you have a vegan diet in comparison
to eating chips and fries and soda,
yeah,
you're going to feel fucking amazing and
people talk about it.
It's just like they did the carnival and
they get and they want you to do.
I mean,
there's pee.
I'm seeing the same patterns that I see
with vegans were these carnivore people
are putting meat and their screen name,
you know,
um,
mediator Mike,
you know,
Carnivore Carl.
There are other fucking crazy people.
They're doing the same thing that vegans
do with our,
on the Vegan warrior.
I'm carnivores Carl,
you know,
fuck you.
Planning poisoned and they're assholes.
You don't even understand what you're
doing to your body.
And then because I like plants,
I like,
you get thrown in and you can't.
You have to pick a camp.
I'm not picking a cab.
I liked my Paleo Diet and I actually,
I'm probably going to try a little bit
of Quito.
I'm gonna.
I'm gonna Experiment.
They're a little bit too.
So there's some great positive
cognitive benefits for that.
I mean,
I've,
I've really experienced that.
It's,
it's hard for me because what knocks me
out ironically,
but knocks me out of Ketosis with the
most of my diet is fairly ketogenic.
Sep,
I eat too much meat.
Yeah,
I crave it.
I'm always the guy to.
Well,
I need,
I think I need a lot.
I don't know,
maybe I'm just full of Shit.
But uh,
I also have a lot because I,
you know,
I hunt elk and shoot a 400 pound animal
and good quality meat.
It's the best.
Yeah.
And I'll eat a fucking pound of it.
So I'm eating like,
who knows how many grams of protein that
is.
It's something insane,
but I mean,
I don't think it's a placebo effect
because I've been doing this for years
now.
I feel pretty fucking good,
you know.
And um,
we're doing this fitness challenge now.
That's what this thing is.
Me and my friend,
Bert Kreischer,
my friend Tom Seger in Arusha fear,
we for the month,
we have to see who burns the most
calories and gets the most maps.
This is my zone thing and I'm planning
on killing those guys.
I'm planning.
I'm literally having them try to die.
Keep up with me.
Sober October.
Yeah,
October.
It's going on right now.
Is there.
Is there a hot yoga and sauna involved?
So I'm doing it.
Those pussies are just going to try to
like go run around the block,
but I'm doing the 15 hot yogas plus I'm
doing all sorts of the crate to one our
hardcore cardio sessions yesterday and
then today I'm going to do kickboxing
for an hour and a half tomorrow.
I'm going to do an hour and a half of
yoga in the morning.
Then I'm going to run at night too.
You definitely should eat more meat
more.
I'm I'm planning.
I want these guys to break.
That's awesome.
Break them.
Burt burt's getting cockies posting
stuff on instagram today.
I talked to burt about some song.
He was real into the sauna.
He's asking,
he's really into vodka and cheeseburgers
that actually caused you to excrete
micronutrients,
zinc and magnesium haven't.
Yeah,
the,
you know what else it causes you to
excrete jokes.
That's part of the problem.
You Scott Damn hilarious when he's
drunk.
It's a part of the problem.
Know again,
balance.
I think this is a very important
conversation to have because I think
there's a lot of people that are enticed
by the magic of this carnivore diet and
I think uh,
I'm so happy that you or the one that
can cause you can do it in such a
scientific manner and just sort of
illuminated all the various problems and
sort of explain why they are
experiencing these benefits because even
brilliant man like Jordan Peterson,
he's a brilliant guy.
He is just accepting the positive
benefits of this and I don't know how
far he's looked into this.
Yeah,
I,
you know,
and also it's important like the,
the,
the fact that the no cbu thing
experiencing bad things,
you know,
also things when you change your
microbiome and you're going along period
of time or just eating meat.
I mean it,
vegans that like eat me or people that
are on a low fat diet that eat fat,
they experienced negative effects.
I mean because they're there,
our microbiome changes that do occur and
lead to discomfort and those things will
eventually go away.
But that was also something to consider
like so there may be a no seatbelt on
top of actual things that are short term
and that it's not just people that eat
meat and then all of a sudden need some
plans.
So like I knew it,
you know,
there,
there are changes that have takes some
time,
a little bit of time in the microbiome
that may be happening because you know,
definitely begins talking about the same
thing.
People on a low fat that you eat a high
fat diet,
say the same thing.
I mean,
so you know,
some,
someone's got to be right.
Well maybe everyone's right.
You know,
maybe there's a mechanism,
the microbiome changes and everyone's
right.
Your body adjusts dependent upon your
diet.
What?
Yeah,
and that's,
it's been shown.
I mean,
the microbiome does change depending on
your diet.
And you know,
if you're,
if you're eating a low fat and then
going to a high fat diet in that
there's,
you're,
you're making bile acids and things like
that.
And you know,
if you don't have a microbiome that are
resistant to that,
you can start to have microbiome being
killed off and then it can cause
inflammation.
You know,
the going from the plant.
I mean,
you're,
you're basically selecting for,
if you're eating a bunch of protein,
you've got a lot of putrifactive
bacteria,
maybe less of the other,
you know,
maybe it takes some time to be able to
like ferment some of those complex
carbohydrate fermentable fibers and
stuff.
So I think that there's the mechanism,
I mean,
it's not even easy to figure out
mechanism,
but there's usually a mechanism and an
explanation for these four things.
And you know,
sometimes you have a hypothesis and
sometimes it's writing,
sometimes it's not.
It doesn't mean what you're experiencing
isn't real,
just means that you don't,
you didn't understand why you're
experiencing,
you thought you did,
but you didn't Makilah Peterson.
So that when she first got on the
carnivores,
she had diarrhea for six solid weeks.
Wow.
That would,
uh,
push through it.
That would,
no pun intended.
Shake me loose.
Wow.
It'd be like,
yeah,
after about two weeks ago,
like I'm kinda tired of shit in my pants
this six months.
A lot.
Yeah.
For her it was worth it in comparison to
the,
the negative effects that she was having
on her immune system.
I mean,
yeah,
you might want to talk to her about the
fasting.
I mean,
trying that.
If she's open minded,
you know,
at the end of the day it's hard when
someone's experiencing it is,
it is hard and it is hard when they,
that's just,
you know,
I,
I get that.
But it also is important to realize that
this is,
there hasn't been proved that she's
experiencing what she's experiencing
because she's caught all plans out and
you know,
so at the end of the day there is no
data.
So you can't say definitively,
but I mean there's a lot of data on,
you know,
why you should include some plants at
least.
And again,
if you're doing this for an autoimmune,
there's a lot of really good data that
fasting helps,
like,
and not only helps,
it helps you age,
like I'm going to start doing just like,
you know,
some,
some fast,
like couple times a year once I've
completely weaned my son how many days
so,
so a prolonged fast take,
but I'm technically in humans according
to Dr Valter Longo,
he,
um,
he thinks that it has to be more than 48
hours,
so you can do like a 72 hour fast and my
inlaws have been doing,
they've done like a couple of three,
three and a half day fast and they're
getting all sorts of massive
improvements in a variety of biomarkers,
a Lipid and glucose and inflammation.
You know,
a lot of things that I know carnivore
people are talking about as well,
but could be getting the same thing with
fasting.
Um,
you're doing this.
Are you limiting the amount of exercise
you do?
Some people do.
It depends on how you feel.
I mean,
you know,
you certainly,
I think that if you're doing,
if you're not eating any food and you're
just doing like a water fast,
um,
you certainly could be more dangerous
and should listen to your body and if
you feel really sick or your heart's
racing,
I think they just need to eat.
You mean something that like I wouldn't
just willy nilly doing as opposed to
what other kinds of things.
The fact there's a fasting mimicking
diet where people can.
This is something valter Longo has
published on in humans and study humans
as well as animal data where it's like a
very,
you know,
like the first day it's like a thousand
calories and the second through fifth
day it's like 700 calories and then
they're broken up where it's like the
first day it's like,
it's very much a low sugar,
low protein,
high fat,
modest carb kind of diet.
So what are the pros of that you
consume?
Like nuts and not.
Yeah,
he,
well he's got like a package kind of
thing that people like can be
prescribed,
like a physician can prescribe it to a
patient,
you know.
But um,
um,
you can,
you can sort of make your own as well
with whole foods,
you know,
like,
oh,
like an avocado some.
Yeah.
But you have to sort of keep the calorie
cap so make sure you're not getting too
many calories.
That's kind of important as well.
And you do that for five days.
What is the standard avocado oil avocado
contains terms of calorie?
but yeah,
you can do like,
like you could definitely do like an
avocado if it's like the whole day.
And then some people have sort of done
modified versions of it as well,
like where it's a little more key to
genic the,
they've adjusted the carbohydrate and
fat to be a little more of the
ketogenic.
And like I said,
I'm the study that was published in
parallel with a fasting mimicking diet
study,
the fasting mimicking diet they did for
three months,
but it was only one week that did the
fasting mimicking diet.
So that the other part or the three
months they were eating a Mediterranean
diet,
the other people in which was in
Germany,
um,
they were on a ketogenic diet and they
were on it for three months and they
experienced improvements as well.
So there's definitely ways to tweak it.
And actually the out getting to the
Alzheimer's.
Um,
the,
the guy that I interviewed,
Dr Dale Bredesen,
um,
he,
he is published extensively and also as
clinical,
a lot of clinical experience where he's,
he's trying to understand the mechanism
of Alzheimer's disease and I'm getting
to this for the Ketogenic is going to
come back eventually.
But so he,
he tries to understand a lot of the
underlying mechanisms for Alzheimer's
disease.
And in his clinical experience he sort
of sees there's subtypes of where you
can get like patients that have a really
high inflammatory where they've got lots
of inflammatory biomarkers.
Um,
they also have high fasting blood
glucose in there.
Little like,
you know,
a high fasting insulin,
but then you can get the same sort of
metabolic effect where you have people
that are kind of on the insulin
resistant Spectra,
but without inflammation there's that
subtype.
And then there's like another subtype
where it's like,
it seems like a big environmental
component like toxic stuff people are
being exposed to and that leads to a
much,
much earlier diagnosis and Alzheimer and
sort of different phenotype.
But um,
he has this really aggressive and very
thorough protocol that's like on the
individual level where people,
you know,
he has tons and tons of biomarkers that
are measured.
One is the fasting blood glucose,
so she'd be less than five point five
actually gets Hba,
one C,
which is a three month mark or a fasting
blood glucose should be less than five
point five.
Fasting insulin should be less than
seven.
Um,
he's got your high sensitivity.
C reactive protein should be less than
point eight.
And then he has a variety of other
inflammatory biomarkers that are also
measured.
Um,
and a variety of other things.
He looks at a lot of different
micronutrients.
He looks at a homocysteine,
homocysteine is really important
because,
um,
there's publications showing that if you
lower homocysteine it cannot enact.
He actually published this in one
patient.
It reversed the hippocampal atrophy,
which is kind of amazing.
So there,
you know,
it's not really knowing exactly what the
mechanism is,
but,
so that's something he looks at and he
does this diet.
I'm this like diet,
this whole lifestyle change.
I mean people improving sleep exercise
and he gives them all sorts of vitamins
and fish oil.
But on top of that,
he's this diet that he is Kinda like to
lower the inflammation and improve the
insulin sensitivity and blood glucose
and all that where he puts them on a
diet that's kind of like,
he calls it Quito flags,
but it's Kinda like a,
a key to genic diet,
modified ketogenic diet.
But a lot of the fats are coming from
like plants versus.
So like avocado,
nuts,
olive oil,
he treats me as a condiment.
Um,
but,
um,
and,
and basically is getting improvements
like with,
with this type of diet,
lowering inflammation,
proving all sorts of metabolic things.
Um,
so it's really,
it's really interesting,
I've,
I've read a lot of his studies because
he,
he publishes a lot on Alzheimer's
disease and mechanisms,
you know,
and he's,
he's got a book out as well where he'd
kind of goes in depth about it.
Um,
so it,
it,
it certainly seems very interesting that
he's,
he's actually been able to,
to,
to not only like delay Alzheimer's
disease,
but reverse it.
And this is Paul.
He has published a couple of published
studies where people were able to go
back to work and actually,
um,
in some of the,
in some cases their brain atrophy,
a kind of stopped and it started to
reverse where they were like growing
more neurons.
Wow.
Yeah.
So,
and I talked to him about this and so
the publication was like the original
one I had read,
which got me interested in his work in
the first place.
When I saw that,
I was like,
holy crap,
this is amazing.
It was only on 10 patients.
It was kind of low.
He says,
now he's got like 50 more that there.
He's getting ready to publish and then
he's got this whole protocol where
there's like just,
he's got like thousands of,
of,
of patients where they're like kind of
treating this sort of individual way.
They do genetic testing,
blood testing and all that stuff as
well.
So,
um,
it's very interesting because it's,
you know,
he's,
he's basically showing the important
interaction between diet,
lifestyle and potentially genetics.
And this is kind of where my paper comes
in because,
um,
there is a,
there is a gene that increases the risk
for Alzheimer's if you have one copy of
it.
So you get two copies of every gene from
one from mom,
one from dad,
if you have one copy of it or increases
your risk for Alzheimer's disease by
like two to three fold,
you have two copies.
It can be anywhere between 10 and 15
fold.
So it's like,
really,
it's called April before it also
increases the,
the,
your chances of having a really poor
outcome if you have any type of Tbi,
um,
and people with that that,
uh,
Lele and have Tbi,
multiple tbis definitely are much more
likely to come down with some sort of
disease.
So,
um,
but not everyone with it gets it.
So there's like this,
like what's going on here,
you know,
there's,
there seems to be this clear,
you know,
gene environment interaction going on.
And so,
um,
I,
uh,
was really interested in this because I
found out I had one of these illegals
and of course that got me really
concerned.
I'm,
one of the things that's really,
really important is sleep because sleep
is one of the ways you actually clear
away amyloid plaques from your brain.
Your brain actually swells during sleep.
Um,
you,
you squirt cerebral spinal fluid into
your brain and you basically clean out
amyloid plaques and a bunch of other
gunk that's built up carwash for your
brain when you sleep.
Yeah.
And,
um,
I talked about this with a former guest
here is Dr Matt Walker.
We talked about it a lot.
He's like him and I were to,
it was awesome.
I,
I just,
I could have talked to who's a
mindblower oh yeah.
I love,
I love it.
Um,
I really loved the conversation I had
with him so we talked about this in
detail because I'm basically,
that is one of the major ways you clear
amyloid plaques,
but the other way is through an Api we
mediated mechanism and April we for um,
does it like 20 fold less efficiently
than someone that doesn't have it.
And so they rely on sleep and there's
all sorts of studies with April before
showing sleep is a major modifiable risk
factor for Alzheimer's disease if you
have a boy before,
but you're getting good quality sleep,
you have like the same risk as someone
that doesn't have it.
And so I was like,
Gee,
you know,
of course I was thinking about this the
entire time that had my son and I was
like not sleeping from us.
But anyways.
Um,
the other thing that I looked into in my
publication,
and this is where,
um,
the,
another sort of diet gene interaction
comes in,
is that there's all sorts of clinical
studies showing that people with Apl,
we for benefit from fish eating fish
where they can basically have improved
pathology in their brain,
have improved symptoms of dementia,
um,
but when they take fish oil,
if you take fish oil and give it to two
people with dementia,
only the people without April,
we for benefit for some reason the April
before people aren't benefiting.
And if you look into the literature,
animals that were given human apl,
we for versus Human April way three,
the Dha doesn't get transported across
the blood brain barrier very well with,
uh,
April before.
So it's like,
what's going on?
There's some sort of transport defect
and Dha in the brain is really
important.
It's been shown to play an important
role in human studies,
but a lot of animal studies and human
studies that have been shown to,
to increase amyloid clearance.
Uh,
it's in humans.
It's been shown to decrease the Tau
Tangles.
And also,
it's really important for,
um,
glucose uptake into the brain because it
regulates the transporters,
glucose transporters.
What was the second thing?
Tau.
Tau Tangles.
So Tau Tangles form inside of neurons
and they disrupt,
um,
a process that's called microtubule
transport,
which is where basically it's,
it's the,
it's the neuron system for transporting
fatty acids,
um,
all sorts of goodies energy to the,
uh,
to the synapse or synaptic transitions
happening.
And Tau tangles basically disrupt that
whole thing.
Amyloid plaques form outside of neurons
and the extracellular space and they can
disrupt synapse formation,
they're thought to form as a protective
mechanism against viral,
fungal or bacterial infection.
So it's Kinda like,
um,
you know,
that that's the reason why they're
forming,
but it's just a matter of clearing them
out and also how your,
how your brain is able to like deal with
amyloid plaque burden and April we is
not able to deal with it very well.
Uh,
so the Dha transport thing is basically
what I,
what I published is,
is,
has to do with the interaction between
different forms of Dha and EPA.
We,
um,
there's two different ways that Dha is
transported across the brain.
One is when it's like in a free fatty
acid form,
it's bound to albumin and it requires an
intact blood brain barrier,
uh,
specifically the outer membrane of the
blood brain barrier needs to be intact.
And,
um,
and because it goes through passive
diffusion,
well,
if there's a disruption in the blood
brain barrier,
then the Gha isn't going to be
transporting very well in that form.
Um,
and it's been shown that April before
actually disrupts that very thing,
the outer membrane of the tight
junctions that bind the outer membrane
of the endothelial cells that line,
the blood brain barrier.
And so,
um,
it's,
it's quite possible that that is why Dha
is not getting into the brains very well
in April.
We,
for carriers,
there's another way to get it in and
this is through a transporter that,
that uses something called
Lysophosphatidylcholine Dha,
which is a fossil liquid form of Dha
forms from phosphatidylcholine,
Dha,
the transporters called Mfs Dta.
And it basically takes the Dha and flips
it down,
uh,
across the outer membrane,
into the inner membrane of the blood
brain barrier,
so it bypasses that outer membrane and
then it gets transported in.
So,
um,
if you look at animal studies that you
delete that transporter,
like 60 percent of the Dha,
Dha is,
you know,
not getting into the brain if you give,
give animals,
Dha humans with,
um,
with,
uh,
a variation in that gene that makes it
less,
less active,
have get neurodegenerative,
a form of neurological disorders and
neurodegenerative disorders.
So it's obviously very important,
um,
you know,
to,
to get Dha into the brain through that
mechanism.
Well,
it turns out if you consume Dha in
phospholipid form,
you actually form more of
Lysophosphatidylcholine Dha.
And that's because basically where the
djs are on a,
on a Phospho,
Libya,
they're in multiple carbons and one of
them can escape a lipase in the
pancreas.
And so basically you can form more of
it.
Okay.
But um,
so for fossil liquid form djs and fish,
but it's really abundant in fish roe,
like super abundant,
like 30 slash 70 percent of Dha that's
found in fish roe,
which are fish eggs,
a variety of different kinds,
um,
are impossible liquid form and you
consume that stuff.
You,
that's the reason why I want to get to
talk about it.
Um,
I order my.
So you can like,
I get Salmon Roe,
I like the salmon because it also has
asked us anthon in it,
which is you order it.
Like is it bottled or canned or frozen?
Frozen.
It's frozen.
I order it.
But you can go into like a Japanese
store,
you can get flying fish roe,
which are much.
Some people prefer those because they're
smaller and the texture,
they don't like the Salmon Roe,
like the occur.
If you go to a Sushi restaurant and you
get like the,
like the shakes that come in like the
seaweed or have a bigger,
bigger,
they're bigger and they kind of know how
to use those for Bait.
Yeah.
Some people don't like them because it's
like squish it and it's like liquid
coming.
Great for catching rainbow trout,
rainbow trout,
eat salmon,
eggs.
So I'm,
so I'm basically,
you know,
that's,
that's one way to get more phospholipid
form,
but also Dha consumed in like
triglyceride form,
which is what a lot of fish oil is also
forms.
It also forms Dha
Lysophosphatidylcholine,
but you just need more of it.
So it's also possible that some of these
clinical trials showing that,
you know,
fish oil failed was because they were
using like the dose they were using was
two grams.
So maybe you need six rams.
Maybe you need for.
Is there any negative benefits or the
negative consequences of consuming too
much fish oil?
Well,
I think,
you know,
certainly depends on the type of fish
oil that you're consuming.
You're consuming oxidized fish oils and
certainly not very good,
but why would it be oxidized if it's
last,
if it's too old,
it's too old and depending on how they
ice,
how,
what the isolation process was,
but yeah,
too old for sure.
Things that are sitting around a
purification process is very important.
The purification.
Yes.
Very important.
And like I said,
there's that fish oil standards program
you can look up and there's a variety of
different fish oil supplement brands
that are on there.
The other thing is like they was just
recently a randomized,
very,
very large randomized controlled trial
published on four grams of one of the
omega three fatty acids found in fish
and other marine organisms,
EPA and they were given four grams a day
for five years.
8,000
patients,
randomized,
placebo controlled different countries
and it reduced.
And these actually were patients that
had hypertrophic high triglycerides.
And also we're on Stanton's,
it lowered cardiovascular disease risk
by like 28 or 30 percent or something
like that,
you know.
So that was a high dose and that was
five years long.
Pretty pretty long followup.
And it was a randomized placebo
controlled study.
Um,
I think it was called the vitals,
it bitlead study.
Um,
but you know,
the other thing that I think people are
worried about with really high dose fish
oil is um,
the potential for blood thinning because
it does inhibit thromboxanes and
prostoglandins and leukotrienes,
leukotrienes and things that are
important for like,
you know,
clotting.
Um,
you know,
I've been taking a really high dose for
like over a decade,
you know,
official I've been taking not always six
grams,
but I've been taking a high dose for
quite a while.
How often do you get your blood work
done?
Well recently I haven't been getting it
done very often because I'm the
pregnancy and breastfeeding and Cicero
changes things.
I try to do it like it ideally like
doing it once a quarter,
but like a couple times a year for sure.
I'm probably troy six months.
That's,
that's good.
I think.
I think like,
you know,
sometimes you can get super obsessive by
doing,
if you're doing it like once a quarter,
you know,
for people that are not healthy,
I think doing it once a quarter until
they start to get healthier.
Yeah.
Got It all dialed in to supplement with
Niacin at all.
No,
I don't supplement with nice and um,
but I'm thinking about doing the
nicotinamide riboside,
you know,
Nice.
And Ken that's been shown to like lower
ldl and they get hired at the stuff that
causes the flushing.
Right.
The stuff that causes a flushing,
but also I think that there were some
problems with it,
like disrupting insulin,
something with insulin secretion.
I don't recall.
It's been like so many years since I've
read those studies.
But um,
the nicotine nicotinamide riboside
beside forms Nad so Niacin is a
precursor for,
for Nad,
which is I'm also increased during
fasting.
We were going to get an,
a d,
a ivy injections.
We still got to do that.
Jeremy,
that company contacted us.
They,
there's two ways of doing it.
One,
it takes eight hours or two,
it takes like 10 to 15 minutes and it's
excruciating pain.
It's excruciating.
Yeah,
they push it.
Yeah.
They push it through and it's just your
guts feel like they're on fire for like
10 minutes.
I want to try that just to see how bad
it is because I want to stay a long
time.
Yeah.
I don't have eight hours.
That's not happening.
I'm not sitting around for eight hours,
but apparently there's some significant
benefits to ivy versions of it and doing
it.
A Ben Greenfield was on the podcast
talking about it pretty much a pretty in
depth.
Yeah.
He's a big believer of it.
I couldn't find.
I actually tried finding some published
studies on the Ivy version.
I really couldn't find any.
I take the time to.
I'm pretty sure it was recommended that
you recommended it to me.
Yeah,
I subscribed to that.
I get that stuff every day.
So that's um,
and there have been published studies,
clinical studies in humans on that,
but I take that stuff every day.
I like it.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
I guess,
I don't know a lot of things I don't
really know.
But um,
the NAD by intravenous method,
it's supposed to be a much more potent
form of it.
And the people that I know that have
tried it,
like the guys at on it,
they get a,
someone will come down to there,
the onnit labs like a couple times a
month and a bunch of the employees will
sign up and get zapped.
So I wonder why some of these guys don't
start gathering data and start
publishing because it'd be nice to.
Yeah.
To would be to see some data on that.
I wonder why,
you know,
a lot of times it's hard to get funding
for some of these things.
[inaudible],
you know,
who knows.
I mean it'd be interesting to see if it
has some of the similar benefits at
taking something like nicotinamide
riboside has where if you take like a
high enough dose you can,
you can raise your,
your nad levels like dramatically.
Why,
how many of those at least tablets are
you taking on a daily basis?
I stopped taking them just right now
while I'm breastfeeding,
breastfeeding.
I'm just always on the cautious side.
Um,
I was taking,
I think I was taking 250 milligrams.
I think
each pill is.
No,
I don't.
I don't remember,
you know,
uh,
before I forgot,
I did want to ask you about it,
but when we butt dialing,
but circling back to this whole carnival
thing,
one of the suggestions was that it
isn't,
is it possible that people,
that some small percentage of the
population would actually be allergic to
a lot of plants?
I mean,
there are people that can be allergic to
certain component.
I mean there's,
there's the whole night shade family I
think some people can,
like they have allergic reactions to and
I think that people with nightshades,
tomatoes,
peppers,
egg plant.
Yeah.
Um,
and then I also people with gut issues.
Have you ever heard of anyone
being allergic?
Oh,
so gut issues would predispose you to
being
well because you know,
there are other things in the plants
that can pop,
you know,
so things people like to talk about,
like lectins for example,
and you know,
lectins there they are,
they are in a lot of plants but they're
much more concentrated.
Something like a legume,
like a bean and,
and they're inactivated with heat.
But typically most people don't have
reactions to,
to,
to lectins and possibly if they already
have some sort of gut barrier or problem
that could sort of elicit a reaction.
But,
um,
a lot of the data out there as in vitro
where lectins are used to stimulate the
immune system in vitro.
In fact,
I've used lectins before to do an
experiment,
but,
you know,
um,
so I think that yeah,
there's,
there's certainly food allergies are,
are definitely a possibility and they do
exist.
So is it possible that someone would be
allergic to both cruciferous vegetables
and,
you know,
a bunch of other like salary or
cucumbers or things along those lines?
I don't know if they're allergic to
them.
Maybe.
I think that people can have,
um,
you know,
with like a variety of different issues
like small intestinal bacterial
overgrowth in their intestines.
Um,
you know,
people that are,
that are sensitive to fodmaps,
those things.
So it's a fodmap for,
I don't have toast oligosaccharide like,
I can't remember what.
But the basically people,
people can be sensitive to them.
They're usually people with gut issues,
like boils down to gut issues.
And Gut issues and I,
and that there certainly is some
cruciferous vegetables like cabbage or
something can affect people.
They can feel bloated and stuff like
that.
Yeah,
absolutely.
But I do think that sometimes resolving
those gut issues will resolve that
problem.
Um,
I don't,
I don't tend to think everyone's like
someone's going to be allergic to every
plant.
I don't know though.
I mean,
you know,
anything's possible,
right?
There's no literature,
there's no,
there's no come across any,
but I haven't done an in depth search
for that specific thing.
So is it fair to say that when people
are describing this and they're saying
that it might be possible that there are
a small percentage of the population,
are there is a small percentage of the
population that's allergic to plants,
that really what you're dealing with as
a small percentage of population that
has a significantly impaired gut biome
that is finding benefit to eliminating
these plants,
this strict elimination diet being on
this carnivore diet which also has
calorie restrictive aspects to it,
and even fasting restricted restricted
aspects to it that this is why they're
experiencing this positive benefit.
And that perhaps one of the ways they
could fix their gut biome would be some
sort of prolonged fast or something
along those lines to try to fix the
problem at the root source instead of
maybe what the carnivore diet would be
as like some sort of a,
um,
a dietary bandaid.
Right.
And I think that the study I was talking
about the 15 day intermittent fast for
were people with autoimmune disease.
We're fasted for 24 hours every other
day.
They had changes in their microbiome
that we're in line of very interesting
changes.
They actually grew bacteria that are,
uh,
you know,
very,
uh,
important for producing things like
butyrate,
which makes,
you know,
helps make t regulatory cells at the
signaling molecule that helps your
immune system produce more t regulatory
immune cells.
It also something that comes from a
state of Ketosis as well.
Um,
well this.
Yeah,
exactly.
They were fasting.
Yeah.
And the thing that was so interesting
and it's a question I had had for so
long,
it's like what happens the microbiome
when you don't eat,
like is it to start,
you know,
are you getting like a selection for
mucin degrading bacteria which are
degrading a certain glycoproteins that
lines the gut.
And you know,
and the thing that was so interesting
about this study was that they did this
like metogenomic analysis and they found
from fecal samples that P,
that the gene in the,
within the existing microbiome,
it was increasing the production of
ketone bodies themselves.
And that was fueling because your,
your gut cells,
and also a lot of the beneficial
bacteria,
like things like butyrate,
lactate,
appropriate Acetate,
no,
these are some of the short chain fatty
acids.
Buda rates like the big one of the gut
for the gut,
like gut cells,
like,
like an 80 or 90 percent are like using
butyrate.
But fasting was increasing all these
ketone bodies.
So it's kind of really interesting
because for one,
it,
it helped and it,
and it basically,
um,
uh,
increased the diversity of this
beneficial bacteria.
It was very interesting.
I wouldn't have guessed that.
Have there been asking,
have there been any studies on
consumption of exoticness ketones to
benefit the gut biome?
Not that I'm aware of.
I mean,
do you think that that would mirror it
in any way?
That's a very interesting question
because most of the exogenous would be
like a Beta hydroxybutyrate ester.
I don't.
The,
the question would be how similar is
Beta hydroxy butyrate.
Butyrate,
right?
Because Peter rates what,
what we're talking about.
That's a very interesting question.
I don't know.
Yeah,
I mean that would be.
Or even what,
what's happening during,
um,
during like a ketogenic diet as well,
right.
You're making,
you have a lot of circulating Beta
hydroxy butyrate,
is that,
does that get to the gut and is there,
you know.
So that's,
that's another interesting question.
Yeah.
Because it is an interesting way to hack
your system is that these exemptions,
ketones like a key gen x or that's one
that I use for a few other companies
that make these.
They do put your body in a state of
Ketosis.
Yeah.
No,
I've definitely tried.
I've tried one,
um,
from,
from hpm n the Beta hydroxybutyrate
Ester and um,
I,
it definitely like gives me energy.
Um,
but the other thing I really liked was
the mental effects,
the thing,
the thing about it.
So a couple,
there's a sort of,
it's sort of a double edge sword because
I feel less anxious when I take it.
And this was,
this is getting me up until like,
you know,
four point five millimolar,
Beta hydroxybutyrate in like an hour
[inaudible] I,
um,
I feel less anxious and more full,
more in the present.
Like I'm more present and not like,
you know,
a million things ahead.
Whereas like sometimes my brain goes
right.
So I felt like,
and,
and this is something that like,
like Dan observed with me,
you know,
because I felt this more than once I
started using it.
I started using,
I didn't use it today but the reason why
I didn't use it today,
so I started using it for podcast or
being talks or anything like.
And the reason I didn't use it today is
because the flip side is it dramatically
because I'm not in Ketosis,
I'm not on a ketogenic diet,
it lowers my blood sugar levels,
like really dramatically and this has
been published,
you know,
there's like mechanisms that are trying
to be explored to understanding why that
is and possibly as a therapeutic
treatment for type two diabetes and
things like that.
But so if,
once the,
once the ketones were off,
which they do after a couple of hours,
I'd crash because my blood glucose is
low and I don't have the ketones there
to compensate.
Right.
Whereas if I was already in Ketosis
then,
you know,
it wouldn't matter because I'd already
had been in Ketosis.
You know what I'm saying?
I see.
Yeah.
So,
so,
um,
yeah,
it's really interesting.
The effects on the brain.
I don't,
you know,
it's something that I noticed and I
certainly,
I'm like repeatedly noticed,
you know,
what would be the mechanism that would
allow you to be more present?
That's,
that seems so strange that that would
have less anxiety.
I mean,
what would,
what would cause that?
I don't know,
I mean there's,
you know,
possibly the glucose is being spared in
my brain for other things.
That's,
you know,
because now the Ketone,
the Beta hydroxy is being used as a
source of energy and glucose is being
used.
I mean liquid sparing does occur,
um,
a lot of times in the context of making
more glutathione because that's
glucose's can be used for energy or it
can be used to make glutathione and the
pathway that does that is through a
pathway called the pentose phosphate
shunt and that pathway takes glucose and
make something called any dph,
which is then used,
which isn't necessary to make
glutathione.
So I don't know,
maybe there's some kind of,
some.
Because you know,
what else does it for me so far?
Fain sulforaphane gives me major anti
anxiety effects and like cognitive,
like I feel Broccoli sprouts,
consumers,
which does affect Gludethyon in the
brain.
Oh,
I never thought about them anyways.
It's all hypothetical.
What about I'm consuming those exogenous
ketones with glutathione?
Have you ever tried that?
I didn't know those existed.
I mean trying.
Oh,
you mean with the Broccoli sprouts,
Broccoli sprouts.
You mean?
Yeah,
well you're saying glutosiome increases
glutathione in the brain,
but what about a glutosiome supplemental
gludethyon supplements?
Glutathione,
first of all,
it gets destroyed in the gut,
but like even if your were to get it
into your,
your bloodstream,
there's no transporter for glue to found
to get into cells.
So you want to make,
I mean,
you can get the precursors to make it
and you can increase the way Broccoli
sprouts does.
It is increases enzymes that make it so
you're making more.
And so that's how you do it.
So when you see,
so one of the things that glutathione
does is it helps your body processes
alcohol,
correct?
Um,
I don't,
I mean,
it's a power plant.
Oxidant
wasn't that what Mark Gordon talked
about?
Lipos.
Somo.
Gludethyon,
yes.
Yeah.
Lyposomal glutathione thigh on helps
your body with the,
the processing of alcohol.
It's a very,
very strong um,
and toxin antioxidant.
And so,
I mean,
but it gets destroyed in your gut.
So if you're taking it.
Yeah.
And also go to thumb doesn't,
it doesn't get into yourself.
There's a video about it from,
from this podcast.
Oh No,
there you go.
Um,
yeah,
that was something about the processing
of alcohol now.
So if,
how would it.
So the best way to get it would be
through sulforaphane from Broccoli
sprouts,
cruciferous vegetables,
and then your body would produce more.
Well.
So from the,
the,
the human studies that I've referenced,
one was 300 grams of Brussels sprouts a
day,
increased it,
go to gludethyon on plasma by Fort One,
point four fold.
The other study.
I'm more recently that showed an
increase in plasma as well as in the
brain.
That was a sulfur,
that was a broccoli sprout extract that
was given.
I don't have the dose on My instagram,
I think,
I don't remember.
I'm talking about the dose,
but um,
so that's one of the ways I know of,
uh,
one of the most powerful ways I know of
to increase glutathione and you know,
basically in humans.
So I don't know how much 300 grams of
Brussel sprouts is.
So what would be a good idea?
I mean,
pressure from wrong would be a large
dose of Electra,
large plate of Brussels sprouts with a
or Broccoli sprouts with some sort of a
ketone supplement
or if you're doing a pure in Ketosis,
whether that's fasting time restricted
eating.
So that's something that I do.
So I am definitely trying to get my
ketosis in or you're on a ketogenic diet
and you're getting.
So the question is,
um,
I'm not sure the glucose sparing stuff
that's been shown in animal,
so I don't know how much of that is
translatable to humans.
What effect,
I mean,
you always have to have evidence to say
something definitively,
but um,
animal studies do show that there is a
glucose sparing effect when you have
ketone bodies.
Um,
so,
you know,
just fascinating.
It was fascinating.
That will make you more present.
You know,
they're,
what's fascinating is that sulforaphane
treats autistic symptoms,
right?
I mean,
right.
So,
yeah.
Right,
right.
So what's going on there is definitely.
And there's also been an open label
study,
so there has been two trials with two or
maybe three and Dr Jed Fahy,
he's been a part of this as well as his
colleagues,
a randomized placebo controlled and open
label,
which is always less open label means
there wasn't a placebo control,
but they didn't measure metabolites of
sulfur,
sulfur of pain and also oxidative stress
in,
in plasma,
which always helps.
Um,
and then there's been a trial and
schizophrenia patients,
so for a grant helps with that as well.
That was open label.
Right now there's an ongoing placebo
controlled trial that's now taking
place.
So there's very interesting
effects on the brain,
you know,
it seems as though there is some
oxidative stress component,
you know,
I have a,
we for who knows how much,
you know,
their oxidative stress may be happening
more in my brain because of we for um,
there's certainly increased risk for
Alzheimer's disease,
increase,
you know,
the traumatic brain injury,
poor outcome,
all,
there's all this evidence that sort of
shows that don't start boxing.
Definitely not kickboxing.
So do you think that mean it seems like
a perfect pre podcast meal would be
these Broccoli sprouts?
Yeah,
maybe an exhaustion as ketone drink as
well,
like the two of them together.
Yes.
So,
so the only thing is like I mentioned
for me,
I crash after a couple of hours where
I'm like,
like it's like really like,
like crashing.
I think you could mitigate that with
maybe some sort of a glucose because one
of the things maybe so yeah,
they say to take when you're taking
those ketone salts or ketone esters are
really potent ones,
is to take them with glucose and they
actually say on,
they say in the instructions to take it
with a high carbohydrate meal.
And so I usually will take,
I'll usually eat a bowl of oatmeal with
some fruit and um,
and I'll take it.
But,
but still it really like it lowers my
blood,
my blood glucose levels dramatically
within an hour.
It's like that's interesting.
I'm serious when I've taken those
supplements,
I don't,
I don't feel the crash.
Try Try that when I'm talking to him.
Man,
it's a really powerful HP.
HIV and HIV and M,
I should've brought you some.
I have some in the hotel thinking about
trying and taking it,
but I was like,
I don't.
Does it taste like ass?
Yeah,
it tastes really bad.
I mean like definitely say,
you know,
so bad.
Some of them are so disgusting.
I did an interview with the president of
the Buck Institute for Research on aging
and I,
I like downed it right before he walked
in and I was like.
And he had just published a study on,
on ketosis and animals and helping with
lifespan and brain aging and stuff.
But.
So I had to tell him,
I'm like,
like here,
I just took this and I actually gave him
some as well.
But um,
because it was kind of embarrassing.
Oh yeah.
I was grimacing big time.
It was like a funny way to first meet
someone.
I know I had just eaten some pineapple
because they had like some fruit
available and they didn't have any
carbohydrate.
What am I going to.
So anyways,
now you know all my secrets.
Well that's a good one.
That's fascinating.
I've never thought about that.
But that seems like a pre podcast meal
or pre comedy show meal.
That might be like a really good idea to
try just a big plate of Broccoli
sprouts,
Broccoli sprouts with a really good
source on the supplements are not.
So it's really sulforaphane.
It's not very stable.
So you can check it into a shake.
Do you grind it up?
So I haven't been doing that.
Yes,
I grind it up.
But you can just put them on a salad or
you can just,
you know,
you don't have to do it.
It doesn't taste good.
Right.
So like that's why you made a mistake.
Um,
so,
so if you're going to put an n shake
with other other things,
you want to blend it up first because
I'm the enzyme myrosinase that has to
come in contact with the precursor of
sulforaphane.
Glucoraphanin has to be in contact with
it.
So it's diluted out if you have like a
big all this other stuff.
So blended up first and then add your
other stuff.
But um,
I've been taking a supplement I got
from,
from France called prostitution,
which is,
there's published studies on it and it
tastes like Broccoli sprouts.
Um,
and uh,
I've been taking that right now just
because of the potential risk for
contamination.
I'm just breastfeeding and you know,
I'm just like,
I'm always going to.
So I'm just Kinda [inaudible] that
bacteria has been shown to be
transferred from breast milk and juice.
There was like that,
that news story where the woman ate the
placenta and like it was like I was
reading this instagram who's a Vegan and
he was going on and on about people
getting ECO law for meat.
I'm like,
Jesus Christ,
man,
you get it from fucking spinach,
Broccoli.
You get it from farm raised vegetables
like stop.
Right.
But,
but it comes,
he's writing in a way because it comes
from the runoff from a animal feces.
Right.
And that's how it gets into.
Isn't that the case?
I don't know.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure that's how it gets into
the food out,
if that's true.
I'm eco lie in vegetables comes from
animal agriculture.
Google that,
I think that's true.
I've certainly had some,
a bad sprouts before store bought.
I was sailing.
You got sick,
I got sick,
you know,
and also I'm from,
once we made it home,
you know,
it just,
if you have to be really careful if you
have too much water around,
if it's too much heat and condensation
and all that stuff to it grows because
you're eating it raw.
Yeah,
exactly.
So when you clean it,
I mean how difficult is it to clean?
Did you find anything from manure?
Yeah.
Cool.
So it is right?
Romance and general catalyst in
particular.
Both beef and dairy.
Yep.
Right.
So a lot of these,
especially like a real organic farm,
a lot of times they're,
they're very,
they have animals,
plants,
all sorts of other stuff together and
the runoff from the cows.
Good side of your Broccoli and all that
jazz.
Yeah,
it's nasty.
And how do you clean that?
I mean if I told you that Ecolab was on
your vegetables,
you still want to eat them.
If you clean them,
you'd be eating that shit.
So how do you clean your vegetables?
I rinsed them.
Yeah,
but I mean,
right.
But how good usually don't get,
I don't know if you knew,
like that's the thing,
like when people say,
Oh,
you should clean your vegetables,
I will.
Okay.
But if there was eco lie on those
vegetables and you cleaned them,
we just think there'll be enough.
Probably wouldn't wash your Greens won't
protect against Ecolab consumed.
There you go.
The heat kills.
E coli and other types of bacteria can
make you sick.
Even Greens that are typically consume
raw such as Romaine.
Lettuce can be cooked.
Okay,
so equalized.
Destroyed at one 60 degrees Fahrenheit,
which is seems like everything.
Trick analysis.
A lot of things killed at one.
One 60.
So I'm so,
but the Broccoli sprouts,
you don't,
you don't consume cooked?
No.
Because the enzyme that converts the
precursor into active Sulforaphane is
heat sensitive.
Is it?
Um,
it,
does it diminish it significantly or
kill it altogether?
Significantly.
I mean,
you still,
there's still some plus the precursor
that your,
um,
that you know,
is important for forming silver fain.
You actually have bacteria in your gut.
And this is,
um,
something that Dr Jed Fay he talked
about,
um,
when I,
when I interviewed him,
he was talking about there's certain
strains of bacteria in the gut that
convert because they have the enzyme
myrosinase and they convert it into
silver or feeding the gut so you can
actually get a certain amount.
He also mentioned that you can take,
um,
mustard seed powder and sprinkle it on
top of your cooked Brussels sprouts,
your sauteed Kale,
which is,
this is what I do because I eat sauteed
Kale.
And so I also have raw.
You eat raw kale,
mustard powder has the active enzyme so
you can consume that.
I'm with it.
Um,
that's the other thing,
like I mentioned the,
the,
there are the supplements I'm taking.
There is one out there also that is,
has a lot of the precursor and some of
the enzyme.
And so you can get a modest amount of.
And this is what was used in the most
recent autism study.
Um,
it's called Avma call,
but the one right spoken
like aV ,
a n wait,
avi.
Avi m a v a m.
Yes.
Av know ab and c o l e V m a c o l e V,
that one's,
that one's probably one of the best ones
in the US,
but prostate,
prostate feigns naturally produce fewer
frame.
Dr Jed fetty has,
has test this,
these teas test these different soul
supplements and looked at Sulforaphane
metabolites in urine to look at like
bioavailability.
And what is the one that you like?
You're prostituting.
I like apropos.
I've taken both,
but it's hard to get in the US.
Why is it hard?
Because it's made.
It's in France.
It's a France.
Can we get this on Amazon?
Know what?
Amazon's got me hooked.
Now that you can get it,
it's just find it somewhere.
A legal website maybe.
Okay.
So that's what I've been taking
recently.
How much did you take?
Um,
I'm taking three pills a day.
I think each pill has 10 milligrams with
food.
Yes,
definitely.
With food for absorption or um,
yeah,
it seems like it can be a little like,
you know,
it seems it just sometimes if you're on
an empty stomach,
doesn't feel good.
Yeah.
I've had a lot of people email me,
you know,
since the first time you and I talked
about,
so for vein,
some of them have taken album call,
some have gotten a hold of phosphate and
some Broccoli sprouts.
I mean,
I've had people talking about like tumor
shrinking and stuff,
like one guy.
Yeah,
I mean it's all anecdotal,
but um,
I've,
I've had multiple,
multiple people talking about their
prostates stimulating antigen going
down.
Sorry,
prostate.
Um,
is it stimulating PSA?
[inaudible] my brain sort of dwindling
out,
but I'm not going down.
I know it's a real thing.
It really is.
It's a real thing.
I mean I kind of,
I feel like I've done really good just
from like exercise and getting all the
fish oil and stuff,
but it's definitely,
there's constantly,
it's just all you're giving them
everything.
Totally.
It,
it's the people that we were talking
about this before the podcast with Dan,
people that don't think that it's
difficult to be a,
just a mom or a stay at home mom.
You're crazy.
I was so judgmental and I really feel
bad.
I really do because it's the hardest
thing.
Like,
like that.
I've,
I've ever done a great job.
You want to do a good.
Oh really?
Oh,
it's the hardest thing.
He goes,
Hey,
job.
You could do with your pajamas on.
It's not the hardest thing.
I really liked these.
Hilarious.
Yeah,
he's hilarious.
He's a great guy.
I mean if you want to do a good job and
you're thinking about like the enriched
environment and how important it is.
I gotta do I gotta read to them.
I got to know all this and then all the
nutrition and knocking the plastic and
the.
I mean it's just a lot of work.
Like,
I don't know,
screamed you don't want to have like you
didn't want to sit them in front of the
television and having them watching
cartoons,
you know,
so which definitely would be easy.
Right.
So,
and maybe the more kids you have your
kind of like something that I can't but,
but uh,
it's definitely a very,
very hard.
It's a hard job but very rewarding.
So rewarding.
Like I just can't even believe I ever
had a life before.
My son,
you know,
I'm just,
my life is like,
I get so much joy from him now and I'm
just like,
how do I get all this toy before?
It's like,
well,
it's Christmas.
I remember before you had them,
you were like,
concerned like,
boy,
I wonder where my time's going to go
from still going to be able to do
research.
It's like,
whooo.
Yeah,
it's hard.
And I thankfully I have my mother who
helps out a lot and that gives me some
time,
but I'm like essentially doing both.
You know?
Do you feel the switches going off in
your brain,
your brain switches over because you're
essentially.
There's some,
a biological mechanism that's happening.
It must be fascinating to study on
yourself as you're watching it happen
because you're,
you know,
the oxytocin gets jacked through the
roof.
You have this little thing that you love
literally more than anything you've ever
experienced in your entire existence.
You can't believe how much you
love them.
It's hard to imagine like I,
it's hard for me as a father to imagine
what it would be like to be a mother
because I think there's a big difference
because I think there's,
and this is one of the reasons why me
and my wife had a deal.
I didn't name any of the kids.
I just had veto power.
It's like you can't call the kid like
fucking turnip or some stupid shit.
You know what I mean?
Like I mean,
it's just nothing.
Nobody but you.
It's in your body.
I mean you're cooking.
It impacts you that I know inside of
you.
The difference in the job a man does and
a woman does in terms of like the actual
making of the baby could not be further
apart from each other.
The guy just does something that feels
great and it's done,
and then the woman goes through this
insane hormonal process.
Her body morphs.
She gains 50,
60 plus pounds.
Her body stretches out.
She's got a baby inside of her.
It's kicking her.
She's uncomfortable.
She can't move.
She's swelling.
Then she has to go through excruciating
pain.
There was a video on dig from yesterday,
see if you can find it where they have a
labor.
I'm recreating like pain device that
they put men under and they have these
fucking macho men that they have this
machine that they do something,
they have these a sense these,
we'll put it up,
we'll figure it out.
How the fuck they did it,
but it somehow or another reenacts the
pain of labor and let's a man
experienced what it's like get your
vagina
blown apart.
That's crazy.
You know,
it is.
You just totally explained.
I mean the whole pregnancy and then like
the delivery and moves just like.
And then it's like a part of you is
walking around.
Whereas for the man,
it's like a,
yeah,
that's my kid.
Wow.
And you get all this oxytocin rush,
but I don't even think it's a fraction
of breastfeeding,
you know,
that whole like nursing,
that's like huge.
Oxytocin lays huge here and then of
course there's the no sleep for like
months.
And for me,
like I,
um,
my son,
like he's seen a bottle like,
I don't know,
six or seven times.
Like I just always been the pool pump.
Um,
so because I was always there,
I,
I've only had a pump a few times.
The thing about pumping that seems to be
really good though is that the kids can
get more of it.
It's like,
depending on how,
wherever it had an issue was actually an
over producer and I had an issue of too
much where,
yeah,
it's like,
he's like,
oh mom.
Yeah.
So I was looking for that and I stumbled
across this syndrome.
Sympathetic pregnancy is a proposed
condition which a partner experience
with some symptoms and that's just a
bitch ass man.
These include minor weight gain,
altered hormone levels,
morning nausea and disturbed sleep
patterns.
Like I said,
that's just a bitch ass man.
Disturb sleep patterns
come after the baby's born.
Let me tell you that silly mag,
but I,
I know what you're talking about.
Yeah.
Some guys say that over again.
Again,
we're too,
and I was pregnant.
That's because you're a lazy.
That excuse you lazy and he ate more
food.
You fucking Slob.
That has nothing to do with a baby being
in your body.
Shut your mouth.
That's.
That's embarrassing.
I'm pregnant to now you're not.
I hate women.
Say we're pregnant.
Yeah,
we're pregnant.
No,
we're not.
we're not pregnant.
Mike.
You're not pregnant.
Mc.
She's pregnant.
You got her pregnant.
You fuck.
What does it say here?
Labor pain.
Simulated here.
Here it is.
Look at these guys.
Do some volume.
Talk to me right now.
Who Do you almost getting to like the
activity
stage of labor where it's really getting
good.
This is the beginning ramps up.
Starting to come down on.
You guys are doing.
I mean it really does.
What's next is these gals put a strap on
on.
They pegged these dudes next.
Just have sensors on their stomach it
looks like.
Right?
It's like a,
you know,
one of them like,
you know there's electromuscular
stimulation devices and they just jack
them through the roof.
That could have put one in there.
Yeah.
Well they put them in their abdomen just
getting torn apart,
but it's not even as sensitive as your
vagina.
So it's.
Plus you're probably not making like
nothing.
Yeah,
it's nothing.
And he's getting up on his hands and
knees like,
come on,
stop.
Yeah.
They just basically torturing these men
to make them feel bad for not being a
woman.
It's definitely a painful process.
That whole delivery thing.
It's painful,
but it is pretty crazy.
It's definitely crazy.
It's really crazy that people make
people in their bodies.
You know?
Like I was talking to my daughter this
morning,
she was getting ready for school and
we're sitting at the breakfast table and
I'm just looking at her and while she's
talking,
all I'm thinking of is you didn't use to
exist and now here you are talking to me
about school,
talk to me about this and that and all
the different things you're doing and it
is so odd that you are a combination of
my DNA and my wife's DNA and here you
are just sitting here eating breakfast,
just talking 10 years old now,
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah,
blah,
blah.
Then she tells jokes yet she's not that.
Well,
she'll,
she'll tell jokes,
but my eight year old's fucking
hilarious.
The eight year old has figured out how
to be funny.
She farts on cue like she'll.
She'll tell you.
She's got to tell you something,
Daddy,
I have to tell you.
Come here.
I tell you some fall.
Follow the ground.
She thinks it's so funny.
She thinks she's.
She's really funny.
She says funny shit.
She's a very funny person.
Maybe she's got a little bit what some
of the DNA from you is a little more
active.
I don't know.
I think it's like she knows how to get a
positive response out of people,
you know,
she knows how to be silly and she loves
that.
She's really silly with her friends and
she's just like,
she's the comedian amongst her friends
for sure.
Cool.
Yeah.
Whereas my 10 year old's not really that
funny,
but just.
I wouldn't say she's not that funny.
She doesn't try.
It's not something she works at.
It's also interesting how they're so
different and they're like the same
environment couldn't be more different.
Right out of the box.
They come out with their own little
personality.
Like when they were tiny,
tiny babies.
You could see that there are different,
you know,
I bet if you had 10 of them,
like those crazy people that was
duggar's that have like 19 kids.
I bet they got 19 different humans.
I,
but they're all totally different,
you know,
a bit one.
I like Mike's like shelly,
whether they're probably like kind of
close.
It's just,
it's A.
I mean I wished that it made sense.
I wish I could get a view of the human
organism from high enough above that.
It all made sense and I and I could say,
oh,
all these little varying pieces are
working in conjunction with each other
and this is why things get done and this
is why art gets created and,
and buildings get built because you have
to have a this and then you have to have
that and they work together and you
know,
I mean that's like personalities,
right?
In terms of relationships.
Like you don't want to have two bowls,
right?
You know,
you have one who's like this and the
other like that.
And together they make this one thing
that's really nice and we've both seen,
I'm sure people that are just not,
they might be really great people,
but together they're terrible.
Right?
Just for whatever reason.
Yeah,
for sure.
It's fascinating.
So
sober October.
Yes.
You're going to be doing some.
I did I tell you about some of the new
stuff in the brain.
No new stuff.
How new past year ask you before we get
going,
is there a difference?
But because I keep this keeps coming up,
is there any beneficial difference
between infrared versus standard?
Well,
one of the studies that I referred to
and that had been published have been
using a standard,
right.
And,
and the,
they definitely work differently.
I mean the standard standard Hodson I,
you're,
you're heating up the air and you're,
so,
you're,
you're getting hot.
Whereas the infrared is like,
it's like using,
it's like wavelengths that are like,
you know,
stimulating electrons that are sort of
changing things and heating up you from
a different sort of way.
So I,
but I do think that the key is the heat
stress itself.
Um,
uh,
the personally I,
that the standard is better because you
get,
it's easier to get more hot,
more discomfort,
more heat stress.
It takes a lot longer in an infrared
sauna to,
to really heat up,
at least in my experience,
they only go up to 140 or something
Fahrenheit.
And a lot of benefits come from like one
80 when you get up to like a one 80
Fahrenheit.
My cranks,
I have to mind your one out here.
You're a regular,
you're hot.
You're right.
That thing gets too fucking hot.
It gets to 200 all the time.
That's what I have to open up the door
to your ears start to hurt and it's not
even my feet hurt again,
it's not even close to pegged.
Like in terms of like the,
the,
the full temperature one,
I just have a really hot one.
Yeah.
So I think that heats really important.
Like one of the leg.
Yeah,
exactly.
One 80 for 20 minutes is where it sort
of like a lot of studies published by
like Dr Dre,
you are locking in Finland.
He's shown a lot of benefits.
Um,
he's,
a lot of his studies have been
observational,
but he's also done some intervention
trials as well.
Um,
the observational studies,
we've talked about improvements in
cardiac,
cardiovascular related mortality.
Allison,
like literally like people,
people do it four to seven times a week.
They have like a 50 percent improvement
in cardiovascular rate of mortality,
um,
three to four,
three to four times a week,
or was it two to get three to four times
a week to three times a week is like 24
percent improvement.
So like a dose dependent manner,
Alzheimer's disease as well as reduced
by like 60 percent if you do it four to
seven times a week,
all cause mortality.
But he's also done some intervention
studies showing that like there's
improvements,
um,
if even a single dose of,
of doing the sauna,
um,
improvements in the ability of your,
your,
your blood vessels to contract and
expand with pressure changes,
which is important.
So it's like vascular compliance.
It's called improvements in blood
pressure decreases in,
in a Syriac.
The protein inflammatory biomarker
studies have been showing recently in
humans increase in mitochondrial
biogenesis,
growing new healthy Mitochondria.
Improvements in mitochondrial function,
um,
and then also improve in improvements in
a anti inflammatory cytokines being
increased in these are all intervention
trials as well.
People that are doing it with a before
doing a workout,
which is interesting because I've always
done after.
Yeah.
So,
so,
so doing it before workout,
it reduced delayed onset muscle
soreness.
I'm doing it before a workout,
which is weird because 20 minutes
before,
I don't remember the exact amount of
time.
I think that um,
it was a little bit of a different
protocol for that study.
I can't remember off the top of my head.
Uh,
I did tweet it at some point.
Um,
but yeah,
it's really interesting because I doing
it before it seems like I'm so burnt out
like after doing the sauna it's like
going into a workout after that.
So maybe would they have the same
effects effects afterwards after,
you know,
doing it afterwards?
Possibly.
But what's super interesting is the
effects on the brain,
like have you noticed,
do,
do you feel any feel great?
Yeah.
When I come out of there I feel just
chilled out,
relaxed,
I feel.
I feel really good.
I just feel good.
I feel alleviated.
That's exactly the reason I even got
interested in Sana was I,
that was,
I was doing it regularly and I started
to notice that I'm.
But I recently met up with a researcher.
His name is Dr Charles Raison,
um,
I recorded a podcast with him.
Very interesting guy,
but he,
a devised this really cool gadget where
he could elevate people's core body
temperature by like a,
a degree and a half,
but he had a sham control,
a placebo,
so to speak.
And um,
so,
so the placebo did increase people's
core body temperature a little bit,
but not to that amount,
not to that degree.
So people thought they were getting the
active treatment so they weren't hot.
They were,
they thought they were getting high.
And in fact he said when asked
afterwards,
like 70 percent of them thought they got
the active treatment.
So yeah,
so it's actually a nice placebo
controlled study.
But um,
what he found was that even a single
treatment,
these weren't people that had major
depressive disorder.
It improved depressive symptoms like
even a week,
week after.
And this was just a single,
you know,
exposure to the sauna,
what sauna.
It's not actually a sign I was like this
like heating device.
But um,
he also measured their,
a cytokine called io six,
which is something that's released from
exercise muscle tissue releases.
It spills out into the bloodstream and
it's part of the inflammatory response,
part of the inflammatory aspect of
exercise.
And in response there's a whole
anti-inflammatory,
um,
effect.
And so,
um,
what he showed is that actually people
with the more aisle six that happened,
the better they had,
um,
antidepressant effect.
So it's super interesting because,
uh,
again,
exercise does that and in fact,
if you give people ensades or like,
you know,
so nonsteroidal anti inflammatories,
um,
and,
and before exercise,
it actually blunts the aisle six
production and it blends some of the
positive benefits like insulin
sensitivity.
So the aisle six,
although it's an inflammatory cytokine,
it's kind of like this,
a sort of a pleiotropic one that it's
released,
it's in muscle tissue,
it's released and it seems to like
increase,
have a big anti inflammatory response
that happens in response to that.
So it was really interesting because the
inflammation seems to be really
important for depression and that the
sauna was like,
you know,
basically basically lowering markers of
inflammation.
So it's been shown to lower c reactor
protein and then also increase aisle 10.
So it's a very interesting kind of
connection between mood,
um,
heat stress.
And then of course exercise is the same
thing.
Exercise does elevate your core body
temperature and heats you up.
And I asked,
uh,
Dr Liaison,
he thinks that things like the sauna,
hot yoga,
hot bath,
steam room,
all those things are pretty much can
give you the same effect.
The point is the heat stress,
it's,
I'm pretty sure that yoga does the same
with hot yoga because I have that same
feeling when I get out of a hot yoga
class.
It,
this is like really good alleviation
feeling.
I just,
my mood feels elevated,
I feel happier and it feels different
than a regular workout,
like regular workout does that.
But it seems more,
uh,
an alleviation of stress.
Like,
I've expelled the excess energy in my
body and I can relax and there's
certainly some sort of,
um,
uh,
some sort of a positive hormonal effect
after it's over.
You know,
some endorphin rush.
But it's not the same as the yoga.
The hot yoga I think is very addictive
to people and that's one of the reasons
because after it's over,
you feel amazing.
You feel so good.
There's studies showing that hot yoga
does improve depressive symptoms.
They're not,
there's no plus,
you know,
sham control.
I think there's a researcher at Harvard
Public School of Health who's trying to
develop,
trying to do a study with how you're
doing it right now.
Are they with her with a control random
and now they're in the
about yoga is that it's only 104 degrees
in the room.
But when you take into account the
extreme condition of the exercise,
extreme stress that you're putting on
your body,
a lot of it is like really difficult
balancing and you're straining and all
your mind,
your fucking sweating and you're not
sweating like 100,
four degrees.
You're sweating just like you're
sweating inside the song,
right?
Like big time sweat.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Like there's certain ones that are like,
when you're do a bouncing stick,
what?
I'm standing in front of me like this
and I'm watching it just pour off my
arms just watching sweat drip off me.
I sweat when I'm doing yoga,
like non what I'm holding those
positions in a non hot environment,
you know.
So I haven't,
I've done a big room yoga a couple of
times.
I've been the hot yoga a couple of
Um,
I do really like it instead of have more
time to see what might be minutes is a
long time.
Um,
but,
but the Endorphin,
you dump a bunch of endorphins with uh,
the sauna as well,
like tons and tons.
And then there's the whole,
like,
you're,
you're making dynorphins which is the
sort of opposite of endorphin
responsible for that.
Um,
so that changes some of the least in
animal studies at Petronas to change the
sensitivity to endorphins.
I'm from the receptor standpoint.
So it's kind of interesting.
That's kind of initially what I,
what I originally was looking into when
I was noticing all these benefits from
the sauna,
but that's really cool that you're doing
it because there's so many studies now
showing that there's benefits on the
cardiovascular health.
I'm also on neurogenic disease
depression.
I mean the antiinflammatory effects as
well.
It's so easy to have it.
I have it right here and just to be able
to get into the sauna anytime I want.
I basically doing it every day.
That's nice.
Yeah.
Right now I've been taking hot baths
just because I haven't,
we're,
we're trying to like get to the point
where we have a sauna but um,
I think we're gonna get there soon.
But a hot baths had been doing it for me
as well where I am like submerge my
shoulders.
I mean you can't,
like if you start putting your arms and
legs out of the water,
like it doesn't count because I feel
cooler if you'd like stay underneath.
I mean you're freaking out.
You're heart starts racing,
racing.
I mean it's like the same effect that
happens where you're elevated heart rate
and all those sort of similar mechanisms
kick into play like they do when you're
in a sauna.
Do you do epsom salt baths as well?
I have.
I really like them,
but I've been doing really hot baths
with epsom salts,
especially like after a very fatiguing
workouts seems to have a good benefit
and and I know from the tank,
from the isolation tank that it's a
great way of absorbing magnesium through
the epsom salts.
Oh,
into your muscle through through skin,
because epsom salts is so high in
magnesium in the tank is a thousand
pounds of epsom salts in it.
It's crazy to make your skin look nice
when you do it.
Yeah,
it just feels good too,
but it's a.
It feels really the tank.
Have you done it yet?
I did it once.
I'm in San Francisco and you can do it
anytime you want if you want to come
here.
I think it was really something wasn't
right because I could feel like the
temperature of the water was off and I
did enjoy what I.
what,
I mean it was nice.
So at first I got in and they had some
music playing music and then the music
went away.
Oh,
to sort of relax you at first.
Yeah.
Um,
but uh,
I did,
I was like sort of in my head a bit,
you know,
in that.
But I didn't,
I kept feeling the water and I thought I
didn't feel like I was like sensory
deprived if you ever hear other than
like when you come down and do the
podcast.
Um,
yeah,
I do.
I'm coming back in November.
Anytime you're here just let me know in
advance and we'll open it up.
And this tank here is the best.
The float lab or if you want to go to
the place in Venice,
but the one you can do here so easy and
it's got a shower in there and
everything.
Yeah,
that would be cool.
I would like to try it again.
Yeah,
I mean there's studies showing,
you know,
meditation and all that stuff is really
important for it.
I think it's an important one.
One of the many components and like
healthy aging,
healthy brain aging,
lowering stress and stuff.
Um,
so I would definitely like to get out of
that thing.
I feel great.
I'll come frequently.
So that's right here.
So I'll come down here early in the
morning and do it sometimes.
How long do you have to stay in there to
really.
I like at least an hour,
but I really like to do two hours.
Two hours for me is the sweet spot.
When I come out after two hours I'm just
like,
so chill out and it's almost like doing
sober October.
It's like cheating because you're
basically getting high in there.
Are you doing it during.
So it worked out,
but yeah,
I mean it's not,
you're not taking a drug but you're so
chilled out,
you know,
and you do have a weird psychedelic
state that you achieve when you.
It's like a very extreme form of
meditation and a lot of ways because of
the fact that you're not feeling your
body at all and it's,
you're only experiencing whatever's
going on.
It's like your brain detached from all
the input of the body.
Some of those,
some of those studies that have been
done on like long term meditators or
even just people that haven't meditated
and then they're put in like some like
eight week trial of meditation and how
there's like immediately all these
changes in brain activity start to
happen like that are basically in line
with good brain aging and improved.
You know,
all sorts of measures or measures have
improved cognitive function and stuff.
It's super interesting.
It would be really interesting to see
like,
you know what,
how that differs from meditations.
One thing I have a hard time with like I
real,
it's well,
meditation and
injunction with the tank I think is
really the key.
I think the tank allows you to achieve a
state of physical,
your physical body not being or not I.
You don't ever completely eliminate the
sensory input,
but you diminish it so significantly
that that environment is not available
anywhere else on earth where you're
floating so you don't feel your body.
Your water is the temperature of your
skin.
The air is the same temperature as the
water and you feel like just flying
through infinity,
you're in total darkness.
Total silence.
Yeah.
I didn't feel that way.
I mean I did.
It was a little relaxed.
I didn't feel like I was like flying
through
for tanks.
That's,
that's part of the problem.
Some of the tanks,
the water the entire time,
they're probably either too cold or too
hot.
It should.
You feel like your brain is like a in
the now when you're doing it.
Is that something.
I feel like my brain is has way more
resource reece way more resources
available to it.
So like if you and I are having this
conversation and we didn't have the
headphones on and there was a Jack
Hammer next to us,
it would be really distracting.
You'd want to get away from that
Jackhammer,
like let's go talk over here until you'd
want.
You'd want to get away as far as you
could from.
But everything is a distraction.
Like the seat on my butt is a
distraction with the shoes on my feet or
something.
I'm thinking about the watch on my hand.
Does all these different things that are
distracting you,
but when you get in that tank,
there's none of those things you're,
you're just,
you settle in and once you settle in,
you touch each side so that you can,
you know,
because you get in the waters like a few
whip ripples and little little waves and
then you touch each side.
So you calm everything down and then I
sink into the water and then I take some
deep breaths and then I slowly bring my
arms,
the middle and then a chill out and I've
done it so many times my body's goes,
okay,
here we go again.
Like it's not like,
Whoa,
what is this?
This is a weird.
I've done it so many times that my body
gets into that state very quickly.
But if I take time off and I do,
sometimes I'll take weeks or even a
month off and then it's a little more
weird at first.
Like,
oh,
we're doing this again.
Oh,
I haven't done this in awhile,
but when I do it consistently on a
regular basis to three times a week,
then I could just sink right into it.
I wonder if it would be any therapeutic
benefit to people with like sensory
gating disorders,
sensory gating,
our,
you know,
in other words,
like you were mentioning all the senses,
other sensory things that are happening,
you know,
there's auditory,
there's,
there's a visual.
I mean these things are our brains
inputting it at all times.
I mean there's stuff going on but we're
able to kind of filter it out and like
you and I are having this conversation.
Jamie's been sitting over the whole time
and like I really haven't paid much
attention,
right.
Attention thing.
But some people like particularly
schizophrenia,
people with schizophrenia,
they can't,
they don't filter that out.
And so like they get overlooked but gets
like an overload.
It's called sensory overload.
And so they oftentimes,
I can't go into like a room with a lot
of people.
They want to like go off and you know,
with,
you know,
by themselves or whatever.
So I wonder if there's any sort of a
benefit for like doing something like
that where you're,
where you're not,
you know,
the sensory inputs,
Kinda like if you could kind of train
your brain a little bit.
I don't know.
Um,
I just,
I,
I find that for me it,
it helps me think way clear because I
feel like I have more brain available to
access.
I feel like if you were trying to say
something that was very,
very complicated and you're trying to
explain something that required a lot of
the resources of your brain.
If there was a lot of noise around you,
you wouldn't be able to do it.
But if there was a lot of noise you
like,
you want to eat,
let's go eat and you're like Bah Bah Bah
Bah Bah Ba.
Some Jack Hammer.
He,
I'm hungry.
You wanna eat.
Yeah,
let's go eat.
Like you could be able to communicate
something very simple,
but if you were trying to explain the,
the various mechanisms are really try
this because I think it
go through like this.
I also sometimes use the sauna for that.
We're all like,
have something prepared.
I used to actually,
before giving a presentation,
I would go in the sauna and I would go
through it in my head,
you know,
so it's like,
that was something that I used to do a
lot.
There's nothing in there,
just you sitting there and it gives you
that unusual environment of just silence
really helped.
Yeah.
So it's kind of interesting that you
mentioned that that's a step toward,
but I think the,
the float tank is the ultimate and right
now there's a really interesting podcast
that's available.
Um,
I've,
I've talked with this podcast before,
stuff to blow your mind.
They have a,
an episode right now,
this week that is about John Lilly,
who was the psychedelic pioneer who
created the sensory deprivation tank and
he also is a pioneer and interspecies
communication.
Figured out how to communicate with
dolphins and did a bunch of weird
psychedelic research with dolphins.
Sarah is from the vault,
John C dot Lilly.
He a really amazing,
amazing guy who uh,
uh,
I mean if you go,
they go deep into the history of his,
his career too,
which is just very varied.
Fucking really strange guy,
but I think is his great contribution is
not just understanding the sentient
nature of dolphins and how incredibly
complex their languages and how smart
they are,
but also the sensory deprivation tank,
which I think is one of the most
underutilized tools for consciousness,
for exploring consciousness and just
relaxation and for me for examining
ideas.
If I have an idea like I used to do,
I just do a lot of Jujitsu and they're
like,
I would go into the tank and I would go
over moves because when you're,
when you're completely,
I would,
I would drill moves in my head like as
if I was doing them,
I would like clench,
hook,
roll,
talk,
grab sync.
I would do all these different things in
my head.
Yeah.
And that would allow.
I would do that to get me to this like
relaxation state and now or I would go
over a joke that I'm struggling with or
a comedy bit.
I'm like,
what is a better way to say this?
How's,
what's the best way to get this across?
Now I'm saying it this way,
but it's offensive or it's blunt and
it's not the funny part.
Like I'm,
I'm taking a shortcut.
Maybe I,
and then I would go over it in my head
and then eventually once I would do
that,
I would get to this relaxation point
where then I could just concentrate only
on breathing.
So after I've worked out all the things
that are bugging me and sometimes it
would be like a seminar on my life,
I'd get in there.
And then as soon as I closed the door
and lay down,
I'd take a few deep breaths and then
it'd be like,
okay,
so here's what's wrong.
Fuck face.
You're doing too much of this,
cleaned you God damn office.
You know,
how come you,
uh,
you only get eight out of 10 things down
in your to do list that's bothering you.
You know,
you need to spend an hour a day just
doing this.
And instead of drinking coffee and
looking at your phone before you work
out,
just fucking workout,
just get in there and get your.
You're wasting 20 minutes doing that.
That 20 minutes you could have been done
20 minutes earlier and then you wouldn't
have to rush over here to do the podcast
and it's like,
it starts sort of giving me almost like
a subconscious of renovation,
you know,
like just,
it's just sort of like,
okay,
like this is all this stuff and your
subconscious is disturbing you and
here's why it's disturbing you because
you've got all this clutter,
so let's clean this shit up,
clean it up,
get it together.
And it's been responsible for,
I think a lot of my focus and
discipline,
like understanding the significance of
that focus and discipline and it's not
just like to be a tough guy or the just
go out there and kick ass.
It's more like to absolve yourself of
brain clutter.
That's pretty awesome.
That introspection,
you're talking about,
a lot of people could use more of that,
including myself.
I mean it's certainly,
I think all of us.
I think it almost really anyone
listening to this,
and I think there's probably one in San
Diego,
so if there's a tank place in San Diego,
reach out to Dr Rhonda Patrick and I'm
sure that there's a place you could use
this down there.
This near you.
I mean I certainly use other things like
a extra running long runs should do
something similar in that zone,
but what you're describing sounds kind
of like next level.
A lot of people get it from swimming as
well.
Swimming because it was just like,
yeah,
that repetitive thing and then you're
sort of managing the motion of your body
and then once you get in it's almost
like a mantra.
You managing the motion of your body and
then the breathing and then once you get
it all sync up.
If you're in good enough shape that it's
not like a titanic struggle with every,
every lap or every stroke of your arms.
You can get into the sort of meditative
state that a lot of people achieve with
running or,
or even with.
Just like sitting there and breathing
like a lot of people get that.
I have a difficult time doing that,
but no,
it's hard.
Yeah.
Is it a funny.
That'd be hard to sit still.
It is.
It is funny because actually like that
some of the other interesting stuff is
just doing that,
sit there,
sit still and breathe changes like the
activation of enzymes and stuff like
telomerase.
The enzyme that rebuilds telomeres get.
We literally activates telomerase so,
so fascinating.
How just like certain things like,
like I wouldn't imagine doing that.
Would it actually,
you know,
changed telomerase
bodies.
This is never ending puzzle.
It really is.
And whenever I talked to you a more and
more sort of aware of that because
there's so many different things in so
many different mechanisms and in terms
of nutrition and nutritional absorption
that I just,
I'm so ignorant of and it's.
I hear all these things and I'm like,
I'm trying to,
trying to get a map of the territory and
I make also,
there's so many things I'm injured,
but I feel like every time I talk it's
like someone's breaking out a little
napkin and going,
hey,
I know you take a right here and you go
there and I go,
all right,
but it's not a real map.
Like the map of the whole thing escapes
me.
It's too big.
It's too complex and I'll listen to this
podcast again,
like I'll listen to all the things you
said again and I'll try to take notes
maybe tomorrow or the next day,
but then my stupid brain will like,
it'll like leak.
Half of it will leak out.
It's like I'm trying to hold water in my
fingers.
It's like I got it.
I've got some water and stop fucking
dripping down my wrists.
So hard,
so hard to get a,
a real understanding of this stuff.
I agree.
I mean,
certainly lots of controversy and
disagreement among researchers as well,
you know,
don't you think
also probably one,
what's so attractive about simplifying
things like Hashtag meet heels,
you know what I mean?
Like people almost like,
yeah,
let's just jam it into a saying or jam
it into like one type of practice and
that's all you need.
That's all you need.
I need is meat.
Look at me.
I'm just eating meat.
Filling.
Great.
I feel amazing.
And then people are like,
oh,
I want to feel amazing.
And then they jump into.
Yep.
You already saw me get emotional.
I was,
yeah.
No,
I'm glad you did.
I'm glad you did get emotional and I'm
glad you did sort of spell it out and I
hope I'm going to send this to Jordan
afterwards.
I don't know if he has the time to
listen to it.
He might have less than us,
you know,
guys pretty busy.
But maybe when he's,
you know,
moving,
going from one place to another on plane
or whatever.
Yeah.
Um,
I just think that it's a movement right
now and you've got to be real careful
about movements because you get swept up
in him and you're like,
Hey,
I'm moving in the right way.
I don't know if this is the right way to
move,
but a move.
Yeah.
So.
Alright,
well look,
we just did three hours.
Nice.
Crazy.
Time flies.
I always love talking with you,
Joe.
I always love talking with you too.
It's fun.
I'm going to take you up on the
flotation thing because I really do any
time,
any time.
Call me up.
It's yours.
Just give me some time.
Just give me like a little bit in
advance.
We'll open the place up for you.
Awesome.
Alright.
Thank you.
Oh,
give people found my fitness on
Instagram,
found my fitness on twitter.
I'm itunes,
itunes,
your podcasts.
And the most recent one,
which is the one that we were discussing
was about Alzheimer's.
And a website is also found my,
yeah,
there's a lot of,
uh,
there's a lot of show notes and
summaries and definitions that help
people like,
you know,
I understand some of the stuff if they
don't understand everything that we're
speaking about.
So thank you very much.
Awesome.
Thank you Rhonda.
Patrick.
Ladies.
Gentlemen.